[Music]
welcome everybody to the H3 podcast it
is Wednesday October 18th
wedes everybody is so excited to play
because today we have a very very
special game we have with us a
22-year-old man who has never tried a
vegetable who of horse is it we're
talking about the Taco Bell loving
chickfila devouring king of all fast
food consumption it is
love very exciting stuff here today Sam
our resident uh Michelin star Chef has
prepared eight different uh vegetable
dishes deliciously you know wow and made
I say prepared in such a way that it
could appeal to Love's palette for
example bacon wrapped
asparagus
potentially something you might so
that's coming up a little bit later
thank you to uh gamer subs thank you to
stamps.com
hold on let me uh let me juice my brain
up here cheers my dude oh man I'm
buzzing
dude yo
also besides that we're getting a call
from everybody's
favorite infab Bren this is
[Music]
a one of my favorite guys out there he
does these Tik Tok videos where he wears
these undercover glasses and
he he makes me so so
uncomfortable um it's it's it's quite
compelling and so we actually planned a
segment with him he went out uh at our
uh at our behest to a bike rally that
was happening here in LA and uh we just
said go have some fun and record it and
let us know how it goes and so we have
the footage of
that which as I'm understanding is going
to is pretty compelling
stuff very exciting and he's going to be
calling in at 2 uh to share his
commentary on the day so that that we're
all looking forward to aren't we folks
we sure are we sure are oh yeah we sure
[Applause]
are yeah excuse me on uh on Monday I'm
having some issues beating the
accusations about uh toilet paper
gate I came under extreme fire not just
from uh the crew here in the studio but
everybody at home had a lot to say
about toilet paper gate uh where did you
pull that clip mayy yeah you said to
send WhatsApp oh I'll send it right here
one sec can you yeah sorry mhm yeah so I
listen guys I really genuinely didn't
know I mean here I'll play it for those
of you just to reog our memories and
we'll talk about it we'll debrief a
little
bit here it is roll it did you just
misspeak or are you putting paper towels
in the toilet that so yeah no I didn't
misspeak it's a paper towel why it's
getting we have solved it game we have
exerc you outside
now throwing down the toilet you're put
Pap towels in there you honestly like
flushing tampons might even be better
like I don't I don't know what do you
want me to
do you're a crial you're the
one you
unfair how why does this affect you guys
so much all right all right all right
all right first of all Zach I when did I
tell you not to flush snooze I don't
know what you do in the bathroom it was
like a was a while ago I said don't
flush snooze yeah how did I know you
were even putting it in the toilet uh
cuz I think one of them did get clogged
for some reason and there was like a
floating snoo in there okay well can
both be true I suppose yes yeah both can
be true listen I don't know what to tell
you guys I have a blind spot I guess
that and that's why we love this show
that's why we come here to fill in our
blind spots and to make us all more
World worldly you need to leave
apparently uh placing a paper towel down
and in it like a
dumpling is not good for
plumbing but I I always figured paper
towels would be um they just dissolve I
mean it's just paper right just paper
right
right I mean it's not like a wet wipe
which are more like f way more
fibrous paper towels are made to suck up
water and not dissolve that's SE
commercials they do Flex that those are
really important parts of the
commercials that's the one thing these
paper towels are so effective they will
clog your plumbing no question about it
see maybe they need to make it less
effective cuz you know uh you never know
those things could end up in the toilet
and then all of a sudden you got a
problem I think they they're too
effective frankly too effective I think
it's a
problem uh here is a flashback people or
AB you you had brought up that you yeah
you had mentioned it before and so
people went back and pulled this clip
clogging toilet unless there's another
another variable are you putting are you
putting something else in the toilet
right we were talking about uh my
frequent clogging correct AB had a
theory oh Chad doesn't know what snooes
it's it popularized in Scandinavia but
it's just a little pouch of nicotine
it's like chewing tobacco that you put
under your your lip which is a little
pouch it's actually become somewhat
popular in America people using it cool
I don't know
why what you tell us
Zach well there's some with to tobacco
and then there's another product that
doesn't have tobacco in it um but yes uh
the snoo is cooked tobacco where dip is
not cooked where you can't really
swallow dip you can swallow the juice I
don't think you're supposed to swallow
the snooze juice bro oh no you are you
are you are yeah what yeah oh yeah yeah
cuz you put it under your lip where it
doesn't really touch saliva right I mean
the goal is to not have that much juice
but you can compare compared to like dip
tobacco bro I don't know I I've done a
fair bit of those when I was in Israel
cuz it's popular there swallowing that
juice is wild to me bro is it possible
that it was uh the uncured tobacco like
like dip because they do make dip
pouches no it was the Scandinavian stuff
okay I hope you could swallow that
because I first tried it here with Zach
and he told me I could or not here well
Zach gave it to me and he told me you
could swallow it so you can I don't
think it's I don't think it's more
harmful than putting it in your mouth
that being said it's so vile I mean the
first time I I tried to accidentally
swell a little bit my ears were burning
dude what no I'm telling you it try one
of these yeah it'll make you pass out
it'll make you pass out the one I tried
didn't have nicotine in it so what the
you guys talking who wants to try
one I do Z do you have them I don't I no
I don't it's horrible for you they are
really bad okay Friday first time we can
order you want me to instacart it yeah
let's do that okay cuz it got it got the
nicotine it got the tobacco all that
makes you dissy as that being
said it is a really disgusting habit
it's definitely mouth cancer Central and
it makes your gums all dark and nasty
really a gross H I think you're thinking
of dip here Zach Are you seriously
deluded yourself I no this is the truth
snooze doesn't cause M I didn't say that
I I I'm it's the same thing you're
putting a pack of
tobacco in your mouth and keeping it
there against your lip I'm just saying
I've done my research on this have yeah
s you can definitely swallow it but it's
not bad it's not the swallowing it's the
it's the act of having something with
nicotine and a whole bunch of chemicals
and toxins up against your lip your me
your sensitive membranes for like hours
at a time non-stop every day it burns a
hole in your lip your upper lip what Dan
put your balls in my mouth what what's
that have to do with anything man chill
it's not funny
um snoo in oral cancer a case series
report here's the abstract let's see
snoo is a form of snuff used in
particular manners in America dipping
tobacco but it does not typically result
in the need for spitting yeah I don't
spit with it either you just don't
accumulate the the
saliva what do you mean but you're going
to naturally just have some you tuck
you're supposed to like tuck it almost
vacuum seal it under your lift well you
can go upper decker or lower Decker sure
so it is it is yeah it does get wet but
you're not like sucking on it like a
loeng you can though that's
crazy Nobody Does that right love
sucking on it like a no one sucks on it
but you'll throw like the the the pros
will throw it into their mouth and push
it up with their th thong yeah that's
how you do it man that's upper decker
right there Zach we are ordering it
will you suck on one like a lo I suppose
yeah all right let the problem is in the
state of California they banned all
flavored tobacco so now they have just
like the straight tobacco flavor whereas
back in the day you could get like mint
or there was like another flavor that
they had of Snooze bro if they baned
snooze in Sweden there would be massive
riots they can't it's it's too big I
know people they like double Dicker they
have like one here one here one in the
middle and two down here yeah 100% no
the you guys don't know this is a craze
that's happened in Scandinavia that is
absolutely a menace to the welfare of
society yes there's stuff coming out of
there that is just going to ruin all of
us I actually can't find it to order it
anywhere I don't think you'll be able to
instag guard it okay maybe that's for
the better yeah we don't need that it's
horrible right yeah that being said uh
possible hazards associated with this
material include malignant and
premalignant lesions in the oral cavity
and the gastrointestinal tract the use
of smokeless tobacco has increased in
the Middle East in recent decades
particularly among teenagers and young
young adults therefore practitioners
must be able to recognize malignant and
premalignant lesions are you clear on
that are are you do you know the
difference between uh malignant and
premalignant lesions act uh yes okay
good my grandfather was a gynecologist
so yeah okay perfect shout out although
an estimated 10 to 25% of the world's
population uses smokeless tobacco this
practice is virtually unknown in
Iran uh the aim of the study is to
report a series of cases of Squamish
cell carcinoma and vacuous carcinoma
occurring in the users of snoo who
referred to the Department of oral
medicine in the Kerman dental school
this
is
uh I mean it doesn't sound great oh God
Zach are you you you're telling hold on
hold on hold on did you see it Zach no
show Zach but I've seen pictures this is
what happens when you do I put it on the
screen that's what happens when you do
snoo brother
I think in swed in Sweden the only
health care that isn't free is uh tooth
healthare and I I kind of really there
might be a correlation between that
they're like you guys I'm not
covering that yeah I'll tell you
what social socialism isn't the only
dangerous export coming out of
Scandinavia that's right there's also
Sno there are there are products that
don't have tobacco I don't want to say
the name but it it's definitely better
okay yeah
okay anyway back to
AB yes just saying be careful Z I
appreciate it
yeah flushing toys down the toilet like
my three-year-old son or perhaps toilet
paper maybe toilet okay so you to be
fair you said toilet paper you did say
toilet paper yeah I me I I honestly I
didn't think like you I didn't think you
would go that far putting paper towel
but yeah I thought maybe just too much
toilet paper right and I do I do
acknowledge the the uh irony of
me saying that what are you flushing
toys down there thank you that's all I
wanted yeah yeah of course paper yeah
too much toilet paper too much no see it
it I'll tell you too much he didn't say
it I know but I don't want to get wanted
to insult you by implying that you would
put paper towel he had just accus me of
using too much toilet paper to wipe my
monster shitty disgusting ass with right
button what you did was far worse
exactly okay but I'm just saying you
know the the man he didn't say it just
okay I'll give you that I'll give this
isn't enough to this isn't enough to
convict in a court of law that's right
wouldn't be enough that's right that's
right I
follow I a lot of people missed it but
at the end I ask if you use a catcher or
like I don't know what I called it just
listen toilet paper has a chance to I
see it's wet and soft you put uh just
like I like my protection oh Splash
protection did you say what did you say
I asked if you put uh Splash protection
ah he was he was circling the truth too
yeah like my protection okay I didn't
hear
that I wonder why but hold on Splash
protection is is okay with toilet paper
yeah yeah but it would have maybe
unlocked we could have yeah maybe un
could have unraveled that a little bit
well we'll have to see I'll keep you
guys updated the next time I need a
splash protector in the office I'll
certainly go the toilet paper route and
I'll give you guys all a review which
includes was there Splash and was there
cloggage do you do this at home that's
what I was just about to ask no people
were wondering I have a bedet at home I
don't I don't even use toilet paper at
home for the what does it have to do
with the splash protection well it's my
toilet I don't care about the splash
protection Fair I'll give you I don't
want other people's and piss
splashing on me bro he's got a point
it's different also my just that this
toilet water is cleaner than that toilet
water the toilet water at my house is
clean really it is clean it's
like double filtered reverse osmosis yes
it's you drink out of that bowl are you
are you the only one that uses it too um
is it your King's throne uh I have a
communal one with Ela at the
moment but again her is not the
same as your her
is I see your your logic here and I I
agree with it thank you Z yeah I will
with that and I'll say this at home I
don't really experience the splashing
that much I don't know if it's just the
toilet is different if it's higher or
whatever it just doesn't
happen it's not a concern for
me I'm safe at home real interesting
real interesting I do I I want to just
clarify for the handful of people that
take these things way too seriously and
get mad about uh Ethan disrupting our
ability to go to the bathroom there
there are four other bathrooms in this
building so it's not thank you actually
that big of a deal it's more just fun
there is okay first of all guys if
you're getting mad I literally just
clogged the toilet as a I didn't I
didn't blow the toilet and be like
these people it wasn't a lot but I I I
saw some people maybe taking it just a
little bit too seriously but it is worth
mentioning thank you lunch time four
bathrooms is that okay with you
guys there's four more because there's
the ones there's ones next door too
exact there's five to five right yeah so
thank you
yeah lots of options so many options
Don't Panic I'm not a crazy person and
my goal is to clog every single one of
those all
right moving
on uh shout out to Ian and Dan who turns
out have really cool Karate photos I
don't have anything like this no Ian
isn't here today yeah he is oh there he
is yeah uh my mom found some old photos
eye of the cobra look at this these
they're at the the the
Karate Dojo making this that's
sick yep yeah so Ian posted this and it
cracked me up and then it unlocked a
memory cuz I had
also by the way that is the most karate
ass looking coach yeah Sensei yeah
Sensei what was his name like Sensei
Jeff that's Steven cagal right there
Sensei Jeff what were you saying Dan oh
just that when I saw Ian post this I was
uh it unlocked a memory cuz I had also
done karate as a uh as a young lad and
uh so I went digging for pictures and
sure enough I found found some pure gold
yeah here's Dan's post uh again I'm I'm
upset I don't have any photos like these
yeah look at that bro with the eyes in
the back bro I know those baby blues are
you wearing like a ninja mask or is it
just cool no I think they just it's
yeah it's at those beautiful blues man
wow cold steel c steel I love that this
one's blue and Ian is red I also have
the the Shadow the John anamorph uh oh
that too it does look like an anamorph
thing I was thinking is it Johnny Cage
in Mortal Kombat who has like the shadow
attack like
that cam says you guys need to recreate
these that's not a bad idea I think all
of us should
just do a Kate maybe during the holiday
for the holiday shoot that's fun we'll
do a karate themed yeah I like it I like
it that's fun I like that good ideas
this is sick fire bender sick I know I
master I actually mastered all four
elements I actually am an avatar what's
this move Dan that's why you're bald
what do you what is this move here your
channeling what does this do I'm
summoning those Flames do you not do you
not see the flames and the uh
the genuinely do you remember what the
instruction was no no I
don't it probably isn't even so it was
probably just something the photographer
told me to do you know what I mean it
looks cool thanks thanks man I am
summoning the the Flames by the way oh
they gave you weapons yeah let's go
black belt you wearing a black belt I
was a black belt no way you were a black
do you remember do you feel do you feel
more confident if you got in a fight I
mean maybe a little bit it's been a long
time I did do I I I was in for years I I
started when I was like really really
young as you could see from I think that
blue one I was probably like eight in
that photo or something dude you were a
black belt I didn't realize we're in the
the presence of greatness that's right
thank you I did Taekwondo for
five years and I never did any photos
like this I was so pissed I did The
Karate after school class and I remember
getting um a rainbow slap bracelet but
not any of these photos well that's I
remember that's how it started I did one
the the after school class and then I
really liked it and insisted my parents
sent me to a real one Club karate there
used to be a guy in the neighborhood
that would teach all the kids karate but
my parents never let me go cuz they
thought he would try and molest me dude
yeah you had me concerned right when you
started that sentence just some dude
trying to teach everyone karate teach
him s it be in his garage yeah your
parents were right s uh actually and
ironically a my uh my Sensei was uh was
an Arab guy Oh I thought okay I think
going somewhere else with no no no
that's cool he was an Arab guy you know
his name uh Mr Mr alai was his name yeah
sounds pretty official yeah was he was
he good yeah he was great I liked him
was he good at karate uh in the eyes of
an 8-year-old yeah yeah he was
really good dude he beat the out of
me yeah
yeah I never did Karate I was not one of
those karate folks yeah I used to I did
like sparring tournaments and stuff I
used to us to fight really y man I was I
was Shi away from physical
violence as a child it it's not that
it's physical I was just scared I didn't
want to get hit you're just yeah
yeah basic I mean I was a child don't
call me a it was like you're just
a coward little
child but I never did at the karate and
uh to this day I still regret
it the warrior I could have been should
have
been
the stripes on the black belt I would
have had my friends would have my
um my studio was very uh uh defensive
violence only you know what I mean we
weren't Cobra Kai we were Mr Miyagi
right yeah that's the old the admirable
Studio yeah who's this AB that's me yeah
I didn't I didn't do karate but my
grandma used to take me to Sears and
take pictures of me in my Halloween C
and are you a ninja here I am okay so
it's kind of like karate black uh Power
Ranger oh from the movie of course I do
recognize how old were you at this age
uh I think I was maybe three four I
don't know the same age as Teddy so cute
I loved you
a I love you
too I bet I bet you were so cool and
nice I love you know thanks Dad yeah
sure you are a great
kid I was yeah Dad uh okay well I mean
great you know my parents are not very
sentimental either like I said they
throw everything out my dad is like
an archist he saves everything it's cuz
he loves you mine too
yeah probably part of
it I love you Mom and Dad I love you Mom
and Dad you do throw everything out
though just to be
real smash I've I've gotten over that
though I've been through therapy and
I've come to terms yeah no you seem well
you seem well balanced
yeah uh come to terms with
[Music]
everything and you know what's the shame
of it I still love
[Music]
[Applause]
you I still love
[Music]
you all right
also don't forget the devil gets chills
when the nice guy loses his temper let's
not
forget but where's the one of half Dan
half Ian because it's blue and
red I need these two Ninjas
a
right Sniper Wolf
update this is a a Sniper Wolf The
Sniper Wolf meme coming up um doesn't
seem like YouTube is going to
acknowledge or do anything about what
she's done which is pretty
incredible they're not going to Sniper
Wolf posted this on her stories
yesterday look let's talk like adults
and outside she tagged me outside no
how'd she know well I know how she knew
okay for the record for the record I've
eaten at Denny's like twice in my life
and I to my knowledge I have never
farted inside of one either so when
you're like eating your grand slam right
and you got to go take a do you
throw the toilet paper at the
Denny's like do you clog there do you
clog at the Denny's is my question here
I don't I have not I've never in
the in I'll answer your question if I'm
pooping in a public restroom I'll use
the toilet guard for that Splash
protector okay oh Fair that's more
reasonable and those work quite well
yeah but you won't so you'll throw like
a piece of the ass paper into the toilet
first sounds like it right right is that
yeah yeah yeah the seat guard here's
what I do I take the seat cover MH mhm I
use it like I clean the bowl I wipe it
all down first I flush the toilet just
clear it out sure yeah then I take the
guard I wipe it all down and then I use
that M as the splash protector see the
toilet ass guards are tricky because if
you got a like you got a bomb
that's about to come out dude that
can like get all over the paper and then
it gets stuck to your ass hold on
what what's getting stuck to your ass
the the the paper man why are you doing
such a giant Mound that it comes
all the only time I use public restrooms
like is like you got an emergency but
those public restroom toilets are pretty
big they're like industrial I understand
that but the paper can be deadly bro how
the one you sit on yeah it sticks to
your Bo with sweat or what or poop sweat
sometimes poop wait wait wait okay this
is pretty wild do you get poop on the
seat Splash dude you know wait the poop
splashes up on the seat sometimes it can
what is going on hold on hold on hold on
we need to uh we need to deconstruct
this claim yes so you put so cuz when I
do it it's not like a huge mound of
paper it's just just enough to cover the
top layer yeah they're thin okay and
then so it absorbs the water and it lays
pretty flat against it right so when you
take a on it I I don't understand
how anything's touching your ass I don't
understand the logistics I'm talking
putting it on the toilet seat not in the
water okay the okay the protector that
goes on the toilet seat right yeah so
this is what so okay that makes even
less sense exactly no I know what you're
saying Zach here's what I do I do a
careful trimming around the Inner Circle
to make sure nothing hangs inside that's
very smart yeah that is very
smart there there's certain ways that
you can kind of just yes work it so that
nothing's hanging nothing you really
doing that in an emergency yeah taking
the time to craft doesn't take that long
I'm good at it you have to I'm fast like
in RPG you're just crafting an item real
quick bro I would rather die
than put my bare ass on a public toilet
I've I've had to do that at times where
it's been so bad I have too man it's
just the worst I've never pooped in a
public restroom that is not like at the
office you don't poop ever he's only 22
cuzz I I think go days without pooping
that's the thing so I never that's what
Taco Bell will do to you no vegetables
will do to
you for me it's beneficial like I shoose
when I have to poop never never ever
poops on his own time every time I was
like I should poop by now so hold on
hold on I'll think when I when I pooped
last it's like two days so there's not
like a signal your body's sending you
like it's time I mean yeah I I'll feel
it for a long time but I don't have to
go cuz usually for me it's like you feel
it and then you go there's no
contemplating I'll feel it it's like I
don't have to I can wait a day wait till
tomorrow why would you wait what okay
it's different that's the beautiful
thing why would you wait though it don't
bother me what do you talking about
don't let say okay let's say I'm
playing a video game I'm in bed like I
don't what you're crowning though like
you got the turt sticking his head Jesus
Christ no it's far up chilling no Crown
nothing I feel like that's bad bro he's
got listen everyone's different
everyone's beautiful thank you thank you
I'm I'm I mean I mean you know I could
only be envious of your uh your habits
and your the control that you exert over
your anus quite frankly I'm scared the
veggies will mess it up mess
up I feel like pooping has got to be
like one of my all-time favorite
pastimes dude what why it's a good it's
a good thing man feels you know it's
good thing it's it's enjoyable thing to
take a nice
I mean okay guess all
right that's fine that you have that
it's more it's more like it just it's
removing something uncomfortable more
than enjoying it yeah I guess I get the
relief there's something about like ah
you're proud of it well wait till wait
till you're a wait till you're a parent
cuz then you close the door I don't know
why but in our house all the locks don't
work so they're always barging in on me
oh no no dude I don't know what happened
that's my nightmare are you like can you
with the door open or do you have
to have like privacy no I usually I
usually with the door open but
sometimes if they're just coming in
there and be being a menace which is
often then I have to close the door and
yell at them to get the get the hell
out that's funny
h two those boys are wild man
four and two one and a half oh he'll be
two in
February yeah pretty soon Bruce is
talking a lot now that's cool he's
talking a lot chat box what were you
saying when you uh during the sub a
tat right right right right it was uh a
TI what was
it I still don't know what you were
saying we like went over it later and I
was still so I was saying like Bruce
when he says Daddy he says Daddy uhhuh
but you were like not shouting that you
were shouting it's it sounded like
that's it sit yeah that's what it was
sit that's I I don't even know what I'm
talking about I don't think he says
that was very confusing yeah you said
that's it it's a reference to Bruce who
says Dad Dad real fast so Ethan says
that's it real fast in response okay
from a he he he does these uh
really powerful con con conjection or
conjectures conjectures yeah he just he
conjectures out like the whole word it's
pretty great he goes May yeah
contraction I guess what you're
contraction yeah which is what the Love
Has when he's birthing a poop baby three
days that's true all right sorry to
everyone eating lch yeah from that
uh coming off of that we are at 31
minutes well you guys know what it is uh
what time it is it's time to talk about
our wonderful sponsors gamer sub is the
first one I want to talk about here
today and wow wow wow wow is this the
nectar of
God it's literally invisible tastes
amazing keeps me
energized it supports the show we have
our own flavor people Sigma brain
everybody's raving about Sigma brain
there is a lot of Raving going on people
love it I of course they do M pull up
the reviews again let's see how many
stars it's got now this this has got to
be one of their top sellers I'm sure of
it look at this look at this graphic
yeah how do you say no to this you
cannot wow and it's a lot less than
Alpha Brain I'll tell you that yeah
alpab brain is super expensive compared
to this this one's like 25 cents of
serving or something I think they said M
that's that's a good price that's a good
price drink
unbelievable uh go uh guys just so you
know Gamers subs.
GG is the uh address use code H3 for 10%
off your order yeah so we went through a
whole bunch trying to
perfect the uh flavors we really were in
the laboratory here giving it earnestly
our best because you know we we'd like
to put out
quality it's just who we are and we went
through do quite a few rounds of of
trial and just being like no no no
throwing the whole thing out starting
over they must have loved
us well they do now cuz we perfected one
the best product there is let me go to
their website let's
see but it's a uh it's a I would say a
spicy Margarita of flavor and I say
that just as a concept it's not spicy it
tickles your tongue it's a symphony of
of ballet on your tongue and not and not
in a painful way in an enticing friendly
little tingle it's like Whispering you
come in yeah relax take off your
shoes sit back I promise if you're
sensitive to a spicy food you're going
to be totally fine with this totally
fine um where is the flavor how do we
all different flavors they have all
different flavors go to shop flavors go
on shop gamer Subs go gam
yep
yep all right there it is there he is
202 reviews W it's getting up there we
need more we need more we need more
people py milk has 2,500 man there's no
way that's as good as Sigma brain
there's no way and they just have the
advantage of time wacamole gamer fart
9000s got 8,000 reviews we need to get
we need to get there people just order
the ones with the silly names don't they
probably uh probably a combination of
that and the flavor but uh but yeah I
don't know the Grandpa's Ash Grandpa's
Ash this is pretty wild you know what I
mean but uh give it a shot try it out
Sigma brain it's Sigma brain really good
and you want to be a
sigma or it's wor or or being a beta is
worse than death
right so uh head on over guys to one
more time for you uh Gamers subs. and
use the code H3 to get 10% off your
order it's
caffeinated or you can get one without
it's energizing it's hydrating it's
delicious there's no sugar in
it sick suckle this
cheers yes
[Music]
sir and finally I want to thank uh one
of our greatest sponsors of all time I
truly love them it's stamps.com
yeah wow and there there's no way to
there's no other way to slice it there
is stamps.com is just one of those
businesses
man there's a reason that they serve a
million
clients and let me tell you why one
obviously convenience
you don't need to travel to the post
office anymore and and I'll just you
know what you know what that entails
with stamps.com they send you a digital
scale you put your package on the
scale and then you print out the exact
post keep it going guys I was feeling it
yeah you print out the exact
postage then you put it on the package
and that's it you can put it in your
mailbox you put it on your front door
they come you schedule the pickup that's
it you guys so if you're running a small
business or a big business I don't know
uh this is going to revolutionize if
you're not using but that's the obvious
reason but here's the nonobvious reason
nobody else will tell you this
people here's here's I'm going to blow
your mind you're going to get huge
carrier discounts up to 84% off USPS and
UPS rates
84% 84 it's
cheaper because I know it it's hard to
believe but it's true
84% and the way they do this cuz like I
said they have a million customers
they're able to negotiate these shipping
rates down big
time and I know that because now at
Teddy fresh when we started uh
fulfilling a certain quantity you get
this opportunity
to negotiate down the shipping cost
which I didn't even know that was a
thing before but yeah the shipping the
shipping game is a crazy thing those
prices are very
Dynamic so old school you got to haggle
you do frankly and throwing your your
money in with stamps.com is the best way
to do it I love them man all you need is
a computer a printer and
um that's it I know we always talk about
Ally using stamps.com but she does use
stamp Socom it's a fact people she loves
it every time I meet her she just just
can't she's always talking to me like
hey stamps.com app is nuts talking about
it and I'm like I know I says Alie I
know it's isn't it great please sit down
stop talking about it no I don't say
that I love no I do yeah I say we say
Dan stop we're talking about our passion
sams.com
yeah also stamps.com automatically tells
you which one's the cheapest and fastest
option of the available options
yeah they've been in business for 25
years there's a reason that they are
indispensable for over a million
businesses I can't say
more I can't say enough there's no
waiting there's no traffic day or night
get your business ready for the holiday
Rush get started with stamps.com today
sign up with the promo code H3 for a
special offer that includes a 4-week
trial plus free postage and a free
digital scale there's no long-term
commitment or contracts my friends just
go to stamps.com click the M frone of
the top of the page and enter the code
H3 thank you thank you to our wonderful
sponsors please considering uh
supporting them thank
[Music]
you
yeah I love that
[Music]
song why is that it's invoking a Memory
that it's it feels like memory of a song
or is it more that it brings you back to
a certain time certain space part of
your life long
gone around the edges memor George
Benson I answered Dan I'm sorry what'
you say I said no I think I've actually
heard it oh it's
beautiful you guys think this title is
good you think people are going to watch
for this cuz I was trying to think 22
22-year-old tries vegetables for the
first time I was thinking game I was
thinking it's not
just eating a bunch of vegetables just
just change it to V for the first time
change what change it to V love versus
vegetables is that what you're
suggesting no 22-year-old tries V for
the first time oh tries V just shorten
Tes V what does that mean good question
you better click and find out tries V oh
oh I see it's the hot new thing all the
all the young people are trying it don't
you want to try some V I want to get
up on some
V female are disgusting oh no um okay so
here's what I want to do first of
all um go ahead just so you know uh it
is just about time for our guest to call
in oh
yeah well we should do that Sam does it
matter if I wait or is it all being
refrigerated it's all refrigerated it's
fine okay okay okay I think she just
needs like 10 minutes head heads up is
that right Sam great so then we'll be
good I have a question um I'm feeling
like Taco Bell now that gloves out here
holding that quad up like a like
a ribbon does anyone else R want to ride
with me I just have to say something
anybody want to ride with me every every
time we we order that it it takes so
long and it's cold yeah it's true like
it's I'm kind true we shouldn't
support them the office Taco Bell is not
good we shouldn't support them it dude
last like 2 hours yeah was crazy maybe
they were having a bad day it's probably
the giant order go it's a very big
order dude love it you said it took like
what hour and a half for you to get it
take 45 minutes that's bro I
think Zach's on to something I think we
got to boycott no we need to contact
them and talk do me a favor Sam open
open the app go to the closest talko
Bell and then tell me how what it
approximates the delivery time to be cuz
usually those are pretty
accurate it wasn't last time though that
was the issue did it but maybe that was
just a fluke see Taco Bell didn't say
like 2 hours or whatever it was that it
took this one says 10 minutes 10 to 25
minutes no way all right let's try it
again that timing sounds nice to me no
way I like the way that sounds dude this
thing is usually right on man yeah let's
order some time let's let's try it let's
try okay send orders in Discord all
right all right so we're this thing they
say 10 to 25 minutes so this takes more
than 30 minutes than Taco Bell is dead
dead dead to me okay this is a big
moment they better step up to the plate
they should send us gift cards and you
guys better save room for your
vegetables always of course there's
always room for veggies right yeah yeah
yeah yes
Mom I got to say I'm a I'm a Mexican
pizza hater I don't that is
gross uh I've never been big on it
either it's so overhyped you think it'd
be like like he has no pizza experience
there's a reason it was gone for years
let's just put it that way people were
all excited it's like oh it's back it's
like it maybe it was gone for a
reason I don't know if I'm
misremembering but I remember it being a
lot better than it's been recently I
just probably seven um I not seven but
it was possible I was just High every
time I had it or that right that'll help
that'll help a lot that'll help Pizza is
actually very nutritious but I remember
one of my great food memories is
when Chipotle first came out I think I
was in high school a junior or senior
that was a big moment it was and so we
used to get high and go to Chipotle and
it was and I would get the hard tacos
with like the spicy sauce and all the
that and it was like whoa dude it
was crazy mhm yeah what happened it's a
you know typical startup business
venture they pump the business full of
cash early on give you that Quality
Burrito that get you hooked it's really
no different than a uh than a drug
dealer in a way you know what I mean
they give you that good H the first time
yep and then then they start cutting it
with stuff starts making his way in you
know you are not wrong dude yep do you
guys remember back in the days when Taco
Bell used to be
sheep uh yeah I do remember that and I
miss those days used to what now like
last year oh yeah yeah and then again
before bics not to be like old old brain
but dude I remember when tacos were they
were like 39 cents when I was a kid bro
mhm you sound 105 dude I
pay4 it's what it is the one that always
gets me is the quesadilla you know they
sell a cheese quesadilla at Taco Bell
now for like
$5.50 it's like absurd that's actually
$7 right after after everything no
before tax I'm looking right now it's $
750 that's the chick
the cheese but even just just think it's
a tortilla with some melted cheese in it
but at the same time also like you also
need to think like selling a taco for 30
cents also doesn't make sense like
something's not adding up in the food
chain there yeah sounds like magic
sounds like magic it does it doesn't
make it's like something is something
wrong is happening in this Supply yeah
so in a sense I'm almost relieved that
it's I and I hate to say that maybe
that's not right to say but I'm telling
you there's something there's just
something really wrong about buying a 39
a 99 cent cheese burger how does in what
world does that make sense that's a cow
died a nightmare people harvested wheat
wait do people still you're not talking
about now you can't get a cheeseburger
for 99 times that promotion the dollar
menu my dude mix skids oh mix skids so
listen to this yeah okay yeah somebody
harvests wheat turns it into
flour bakes that into a bun pows are
slaughtered right they are processed
into ground beef sent to McDonald's all
of this stuff is sent on massive
expensive trucks with drivers huge gas
bills they're sent all around the
country to McDonald's you've got lettuce
tomato cheese these are all coming on
massive trucks picked produced somewhere
these all these ingredients come
together in a Taco Bell or in a
McDonald's wrapped in plastic handed to
you by somebody these people are all
being paid all CA and and then it's 99
Cents it doesn't make sense talk about
sense doesn't make sense do you guys
know what I mean but anyway God bless
[Music]
it God bless
it we love our cheap Burgers don't we we
we do we love our cheap uh food folks it
doesn't get any better got me through
college Amen brother oh man I used to
hit talko about all the time in college
there was one in Santa Cruz right on
like the main strip it was so seedy and
gross but we used to hit that place
I'll never forget I was I was super
broke and I bought two of like the 99
McNuggets and one was for dinner and the
next one was for breakfast the next day
and I saved it I put in the fridge and I
woke up the next day my roommate ate it
and put a dollar Inside the Box and it
was the most audacious thing I've ever
seen in my life that's brutal dude
that's but just to go back to what you
said those are hard times my friend one
taco in the night and one taco in the
morning yeah that's not enough
food when I I moved out when I was like
18 I was I was still really young so I
don't know I my room was actually a
closet and my I lived in a closet
actually when I was in college I did
that I lived in a closet it was an attic
closet it was really a weird spot for me
uh but surprisingly it didn't really
care that much I was playing World of
Warcraft and uh you don't need a lot of
space for that you don't frankly you it
was a sad sight I would sit there with a
laptop on my stomach a mous on my side
and I would just lay there with Taco
Bell I think I had a job but maybe like
three times a week or something that was
so sick I love playing W when I was a
kid did you guys have trouble finding a
job when you're college cuz I don't know
what it's like but in Santa Cruz it was
so hard to get employment cuz
there's so many college kids and just
not enough business there I was a part
of the work study program at school so
they just they just pass them out like
free candy oh work oh they didn't even
pay you no they do but it was just like
a token amount exactly yeah a
nightmare hi may all right here's what I
want I also want to add a combo hereo
I'm just delaying cuz
I cuz I'm still working on my order I
want the burrito supreme
combo and I want
it I need it
actually
[Music]
mhm what I need wow they have a lot of
drink options that's always been a nice
thing about Taco Bell they have crazy
good drink options they do right it's
the biggest drink in the night of the
year
yeah
um they have Pepsi Zero do they have a
root beer zero cuz that's what I could
with right now wait they have Pepsi
Zero there I still haven't tried that
what they have Baja Blast zero as well I
well not as good it's not as good they
don't have Baja Blast zero as an option
for this location wait I see it no no no
no no no no no no don't say that I see
it I see it Sam that's right that hold
on it's it's not true hold on hold on
hold on hold on you see it you're
probably looking at different stores no
no no no we're looking at the same one
or you hold on Sam I'm not going to say
the address I'm not going to say the
address but I'm going to send it on
WhatsApp and you tell me if this is the
one you're looking
at cuz it says 10 to 25 minutes yo
that's the one I was looking at I'm
going to have a Mountain Dew bioblast
freezy yo
same I'm looking at the same one but
they bro okay so go to go to
beverages okay okay hold on where's the
damn beverages now dude this is like
dessert for me I just had Taco Bell and
now I get Taco Bell
dessert I love it I also saw you eat a
giant bowl of something before your Taco
Bell even got here what do you eat
before Taco Bell uh some cir with
cookies
in jeez man I miss being that I miss
Ethan as part of your combo do you want
the crunchy taco supreme yes please got
it so no uh cookies for
you I miss being like that man love it
was so nice just being a to do I'm in
the drink section I do not see now I
can't find the drinks where the did
drinks go they just sold out it's they
do not have they do they oh here it is
here it is okay here's what you need to
do listen and listen
carefully listen carefully to these
instructions that I'm about to tell you
L
dud okay this looks different I don't
know why listening in we have we have a
um a guest waiting on standby oh
here just give me the Mountain Dew zero
then okay got it thank you all right so
whoa out of the Taco Bell
Vortex so we have today a really
exciting segment planned is this on V is
this something you're going to launch
yeah yeah I have it uh on my end here so
infab brand is a friend of the show he
is a maniac on Tik Tok hear wears spy
glasses
and I don't know if I want to say
harasses people in like uh grocery
stores and stuff but I also wouldn't say
that that's not a necessarily an
incorrect you're playing pretty fast and
loose with these harassment allegations
calling your
representatives yeah he's you know what
he's doing he's voicing his political
opinion M I heard I heard someone use
the term heriz maybe he horing horing
them I like that I like that um we've
watched a few let me just show you what
you guys are getting yourselves into but
he called into the show and he was great
everybody loved him so we
basically heard he was going to be in
La so we had the pleasure of uh sending
him out to we we found a kind of an
event that was happening a bicycle rally
here in Los Angeles
cavia see cavia cavia cavia he keeps
saying it oh he says it cavia right
that's what he and I haven't seen this
yet but I've heard I've been hearing
about it I got to say I cut this down to
like less than five minutes but he sent
so much gold I almost want to like can I
make like a longer version for the we
can do a super long one for highlights
Channel definitely that'd be awesome you
could just throw it all up there and I
also just want to say this comes from
his brain his idea of what what is a in
this sketch in this bit something you
and I can't think of but only he can
think of he has a beautiful mind yes and
basically we commissioned him we said
friend we want to support you we want
you to be on the show go out there and
just do whatever it is you do and then
report back to us but that's what we
have I'm going to show you one of his
videos just to catch you
up
yier
laesa
he is out out out of
[Music]
controlo it's important to remember that
he's wearing spy glasses so nobody
know
uh yeah
Tres they're scared I'm sure of it uhhuh
this crazy white guy
yeah I feel so uncomforable
uh is on
youo
ah oh my
God you feel bad you do
[Laughter]
feel yo
espito uhhuh yeah du
lingo
uh yo manzanas
uh
[Laughter]
[Music]
manzanas he does no
little he answers the phone this way uh
ibers
seebers okay us
no this is the weirdest thing that's
ever happened to these guys they're
going to talk about this
forever you know in a sense it's a
beautiful bonding experience that he's
put these friends through that have this
cherish memory yeah uh yeah you're right
F they're so nice and so patient by the
way yeah
see
BU
okay amig go he just doesn't
leave DOL for Di high five my
god oh he's getting dabbed up
by the top comment he said bro made him
so uncomfortable they forgot
beer which is so damn true I think they
just wanted to get away that is so funny
a hilarious observation oh
mananas uhhuh so so anyway just to give
you a little example there's endless
amounts of these so without further Ado
this is infer brand at the Los
Angeles uh bicycling
Bonanza hey folks it's bread yesterday
these streets were filled with bikes and
today they
aren't I took to the streets myself on a
bicycle with a couple buckets of Sardine
paste for the Riders
let's have a look at what I saw through
my hidden camera
glasses dolphin
die5 I am not a threat I just want to
chat for a bit how you doing I just want
to ask you some questions about the
event is this all right sure okay what's
going on here uh so they're doing CIA
could freely bicycle run okay uh well
I'll tell you what I see a lot of
and kneecaps bouncing up and
down and I love
it I love it lots of goodl looking folks
through where no one's
been but it feels like home oh
boy you're catching up to me I'm letting
you get ahead I'm going to whoop all
your asses in this one you're wondering
what this is what is it ice cream no
it's a fish paste oh a medal of sorts ah
interesting for the Riders it's for them
to dunk their heads into okay you want
to dunk your head in it it's good for
for the scalps good for the
[Music]
decaps beautiful people out here at the
uh Napoleon what are you doing I got
clams sardines anchovies a little bit of
Tuda and you some pink salmon pink fish
paste careful careful about the bug
careful about the
buckets careful about the
buckets I'm good no no no no just
leave it
man just leave it
bro the Sardine takes came in out of the
bucket
huh uh hello
hi look at you what
[Music]
huh go Bud you'll be all right you'll be
real cool goby do
it oh yeah oh
yeah oh get the back of the head in
there come on come on you got it you got
it there you go
buddy look at you look at you buddy hey
hey no it's okay you got it good boy
good
boy and that's what this is all about
the
clavia yeah you got a burrito in your
pocket hey hey
hey hey come on come on now what are you
the hell are you doing that's not a
bike bro Jesus
Christ I'm pissed off come on
guess one of those folks to drive down a
oneway street going all the way down the
street ain't seeing nothing and I'll
tell you what I bet they've never dunked
their head in sardine paste a day in
their life buddy know but you know what
let him kill somebody hi there hi there
hi hi can I talk to you about your
banana suit hey why are you riding today
I'm not riding I'm walking oh bicycle
Pete with a tight fickle feet look at
those puppies oh yeah oh but goody dude
you want to pop a shoe off for me no I'm
good all right cool doph
die
hi wow hello look it Smiles all the way
all righty give these a whiff
huh prob a good time right there let me
tell
you hey there bicyle I spy a nice
pickle how hey how how many NPS does
this baby get MPS NPS meters per spin
eight you would say so huh isn't that
right and you look parts do you want
some uh huh little bit of dolphin milk
here
dolphin yeah it's milked dolphin on
purpose come Bud it got enough of your
punishment nice talking to you I'm going
to move on I close my eyes and I can see
a world that's waiting up for me and I
call my
own Through The Dark Through The Doors
through where no one's been
before but it feels like home oh
boy wow
wow well it's every bit as wild as I
anticipated cam you should just just
upload it all on the cliff Channel cuz
I'll watch all of it uh sure I'll have
to like cut around stuff you know what I
mean like C you know yeah with within
reason I mean there's just like dead air
and stuff too that'll yeah yeah yeah of
course so joining us now I believe he
should be on the phone with us is infa
Bren
himself Saturdays are for the
boys hello infer Bren how are
you well kiss me in the moon bite you're
like fishy kind of stews right right
right yeah so how was the bicycle event
you seem to really fit in there oh it
was fantastic man I really got a kick
out of going to that thing huh yeah and
and and I was happy to see that people
were quite receptive to the fish paste I
think you refreshed a lot of people out
there well fish paste is actually good
for the scalp it's also good for the
kneecaps and increases your
nps's which is meters per spin right so
it helps you get along a little faster
Ethan that's the thing so what you're
putting the you're putting the it in
your wheels or something how does it
increase no you put it on your head oh
okay
okay well
um yeah I I I what did you think of the
edit do you think we we accurately
captured the day or who edited that that
was actually that was really good that
was uh that was cam of
course yeah good job cam yeah cam did a
great job he did great job Cam that was
amazing thank you thank you thank you
well um I think it was a hit um I just I
absolutely adore the the scooping of the
the fish paste whatever happened with
the fish paste did we get it all up off
the the
street uh I believe we probably salvaged
about 69% of it off the street that was
devastating that fall by the way yeah it
looked bad felt bad because it's not
just any ordinary sardine Pace that is
three years aged okay so I had that
sitting in the trunk of a Honda ACC cord
for three hot summers wow and seeing
that happen definitely uh it definitely
induced some heart pal itations right um
a minor existential crisis right so to
speak right I hate when that happens
yeah but the good new terrible the good
news at least is that if you're crashing
and hurting your
knees the fish paste is right
there in a sense that that's good I got
to take my medication go ahead I
understand take your
time uh bre is he has a some kind of
vial that he's slamming against his hand
oh just wait what is that e what is that
bro
sardines what the yeah you just eat
it like that
huh I can't believe they're selling your
in Aspirin bottles now that doesn't
make any sense yeah that doesn't make
sense no it doesn't make sense I can't
believe you bought it in an aspirin
bottle I did actually buy it in in an
aspirin bottle Ethan yeah no that's what
you said I heard I it's really
unbelievable
um how do you feel do you think we could
said Bren the fist Fest I mean that's my
dream that would be amazing bro
that's kind of the ultimate goal for all
this what's going on with the pickle guy
is this someone you know is this a
organization you're involved with this
guy right here yeah that's Kenneth you
don't know Kenneth uh no I I don't oh
Kenneth's a legend he loves pickles he
also loves eating booty matter of fact
pickles sphincter was inspired by this
guy I made it for him oh that that
flavor yeah based off these two things
that he enjoys
wow I like that's a really nice
backstory yeah no he's an amazing guy so
just to go back to the bicycle rally I
mean did you enjoy your time in Los
Angeles did you um did you meet lots of
Ni nice people out there overall what
was your impression of the beautiful
city of Los Angeles and the bicycle
event very different from Washington
State a little too hot for me I'll tell
you this um special shout out to Blake
Roser for putting me up on his air
mattress during the weekend amazing guy
you might in the video he dunked his
head in some of the s that was
him yeah oh shout out to bla yeah
terrific guy I tried to make a team and
so if you're staying at his house then
you probably know how did that wash
out it dried up in his scalp pretty bad
oh God pretty bad he was in the shower
for at least two
hours that probably one hour was you
know uh washing the Sardine paste out
his scalp I'm guessing the second hour
was
masturbation um right because you don't
need two hours yeah of course yeah yeah
so um so shout out to Blake very much so
um we love high five yeah absolutely
right there high five brother right
there well uh it's been a pleasure it's
been a joy I hope you're you'd like to
do more events the next fishfest is
April 25th to April
27th does that have something to do with
fists oh I think we talked about it
before and you said you might be
uncomfortable with it it's it's a i well
let me tell you I think so maybe it was
someone else uh a friend of the show
Hunger FF is one of the main attendees
there which is actually would be really
good cuz we'd have a really good we have
an in we we can get backstage passes oh
he's like the king he would be the best
walk through and um it's an event where
a bunch of men who uh who enjoy the the
practice the art I would even say of
fisting oh
oh yes and they just and it's just a lot
of that essentially and I loveis okay
good okay yeah it's a whole
festival it's a it's a very it's a very
you know tight-knit Community as I
understand it but they're very they are
very serious professionals and he he is
quite good at what he does okay yeah uh
uh TNC as Kenneth would say h
TNC Titan it Community Titanic Community
oh you you know about those ones huh oh
yeah so you dude so um one of the pieces
of footage and I don't know what
happened to it my fault not your not the
editor's fault but I did this bit while
I was out there too where I was pouring
the Sardine paste into Little Dixie Cups
and I was standing on the
sidelines and as the writers were like
going byd be like hey come on good job
folks and they just take it because they
think it's water or
something you know and they'd be riding
off and you know put it to lips what the
is this you know wait I don't think
I got that footage no no I I don't know
what happened to it at some point my
glasses died or something oh man sounds
that sounds pretty hectic though did
anyone drink
it I don't know they were riding off it
looks like a couple people like almost
did and they're like what the hell is
this did did did any confrontation take
place out there on the street was there
anyone who got upset or is everyone just
kind of too awkward and scared in a
sense to confront you uh most people
were just too uh awkward and scared to
from me I didn't really have any
situation go on down
there um yeah I I find that typically
most people just I got I got a friendly
face you know so most people kind of go
this guy's mentally ill probably but uh
he's not like a threat I don't think
right he's not
threatening that's important I'll tell
let me read you some about fist Fest on
the this is from the website it says
what can you expect hot men Hot Hands
hot holes and lots of
them that's the description from the
website okay go on it's a weekend event
the infamous afternoon pool party it's
got a open bar slings benches play
supplies Rock and music and then at
night they've got the hell
hole at the edge of hell party you don't
want to M as in a hole yeah probably
play on words body hole Yeah Yeah night
Dusk to Dawn pool
party and they say the the full moon
weekend but they say FF like fist
how late and they said they ask
how late can you stand up fist fist
partners with the handball Academy which
provides educational opportunities
throughout the
weekend well oh that's so good cuz like
I feel like this is going to be
educational and a really valuable
insight into this kind of niche of the
these really s these professionals and
so I feel that that is important uh to
report on says prizes and giveaway so
pay attention our cocktail party
including hosted heavy appetizers and of
course there's the pig pen of which they
do not elaborate
on okay I know what it is
yeah I'll elaborate when I do it you'll
see Fant I mean
golly G wiiz man we got to get you out
there okay great so we'll if you're
interested we can start the doing prep
and getting tickets and talking seeing
if hunger is down to kind of host host
you're if that's something you're
interested in 100% 100 100% fantastic
wow that's exciting to me that's
exciting well thanks for um you know
thanks for working with us uh really
really nice it was a pleasure thank you
so much for having me back on love
seeing you folks yeah nice to see what
you do
Ethan you had the silkiest little
eyelashes okay sel's as kith would say
remember this H I used to pluck those
puppies off one at a time make a wish
and blow them out mine yeah I don't
remember that I don't recall that all
right well you know
[Laughter]
happens just saying I don't I don't
remember that happening you don't
remember it happening but it happened
okay it didn't just be clear everyone
watching crystal clear it sure did
here's another excerpt so this is
actually good that we're friends with
Hunger it says we are a private event
not open the general public you'll need
to get on our newsletter email list the
way that you can keep a breast of all
the announcements leading up to the
event so we got to let's reach out to
hunger and see if he can get us press
pass you got
it that's exciting I'm very excited for
for our future collabor
ations I'm very excited in general you
know everything you do excites me
everything Zach does excites me Dan Dan
did you get my Cameo remember the Cameo
I did yes I I do I do remember the Cameo
what do you think yeah I was a little
little scared is this a real thing wait
what do you mean okay yeah I did a cameo
for him yeah right yeah I don't know why
you I don't know how you found out like
all my extended family members address
oh that's up come
on I won't share that information my
secrets are secret yeah appreciate that
INF for Bren one last question before we
go your thoughts on Israel versus Gaza
all right Bren we got to go thank you so
much
byebye what does that say that this is
vocal Lube do you want to see what it
does yeah I'd love to all right check
this
[Music]
out
you know where love was meant to
be the kind of love that
forever and I want you thank you infa
Bren everybody nice to hear from you
nice to see
you he he is
great go ahead
D know thank you thank you br
I nice to hear from him and he and there
he is this is wow always a pleasure wow
marvelous I am
genuinely someone said someone's going
to kill him that was my that's my fear
in a sense too but uh I don't I don't
take on that responsibility nah no that
won't happen um mind so here's the thing
I think that this fist Fest thing if we
can coordinate with with Hunger could
really be uh really something special
all right we'll see what hunger we'll
see what hunger says I don't know I mean
I know he loves us but you don't think
he'll get him in I just don't know okay
I mean Zach you know him well I'll I'll
give him a shout later and we'll it just
seems like this is a very
um sacred thing to that Community you
know what I mean what about it told you
that it was sacred the uh that message
the hell hole it Pig
it seems pretty sacred I mean they even
have uh a program for it says our
brothers in recovery where during the
day they have someone meet with them for
meetings to help them get through uh
recovery oh okay I think you're right in
the sense Dan but I also think these
guys have a really good sense of humor I
mean you've seen they said hot men hat
hands hat Hole Hot holes and lots of
them I mean these these guys they're
they're good sports they have a good
sense of humor about it right yeah
surely and genuinely I'm not there there
to ridicule uh we're there on a fact
finding mission of
Education there it
is thank you
everybody are we I smell the food
heating up Sam is that what's happening
is it
time is the Taco Bell here no it's think
it's been 10 minutes so the good the you
saved a CH a a Doritos crunch taco right
I did I have a a little bit of a PO
cleanser so so what we prepared for love
so he doesn't get overwhelmed you know
when people they experiment with uh
delicate or extreme flavors it's
frequent to have a pallet cleanser
sometimes it's a lour sometimes it's a
piece of ginger in this case uh love
will be taking a bite of the Dorito
shell crunchy
taco and take the wrapper off this time
love in between each course just to
clean his Paladin to reset
so as we actually I'm going to go to the
bathroom real fast as we set up for this
so I'll be right back and we will
continue with 22-year-old tries
vegetables for the first time
what wow wow Ian what do you think about
uh this whole vegetable
argument M you know after uh impra does
uh fist Fest maybe go to Mecca next just
send him to Mecca the other the yeah
exactly right yeah that's a good idea we
should definitely do that um there's a
$100 donation that I wanted to get to
from a foa trooper by the name of
emerald however I got to say I don't
know what it means says can't type
message sent message Zach
Cameo She's been sending messages like
that all day I don't really know what it
means um we see your message we
appreciate the donation uh we love you
cheers my dude um I just I got a
message are they telling you to check
your cameo yeah yeah yeah oh oh sorry
sorry there's zachie there's zachie uh
Ian why do you keep switching to the
wrong thing what are you doing
dude it's actually from two different
people there's one from a person named
Amy and one from Emily H well their name
is Emerald but that's just their YouTube
name so uh uh it won't let me send a
$100 Super Chat no matter what I do
anyway I'm a rockhound I've mined J in
California uh be more than happy to
bring my Rocka and raw Jade to
La wait okay so we can cut open Jade and
then they have a Tik Tok um if I if I
can shout that out okay it's called dig
crystals I dig Crystal I mean their name
is Emerald they dig crystals they have
raw Jade sounds
legit sounds like they're Jade head to
me credentials are stack straight up
Jade head so shout out to uh Emily and
uh Amy shout out thank you for the Super
Chat apparently your uh Super Chat did
go through so I hope you didn't not
intend to give us $100 accidentally did
that uh somebody just donated 10
Australian dollars said yo Ethan I'm
also on a weight loss journey and I've
already lost 30 lbs can I get a shout
out well Ethan isn't here at the moment
he might be clogging up the toilet Che
my dude but uh congrats on that that's
that's incredible 3 lb is significant oh
this person has a huge following on uh
on Tik Tok Emerald here yeah 1.5 million
okay well maybe we can maybe we can get
together and cut open some rocks i' be
Wicked bro how cool would that
be that sounds like so much fun field
trip field trip
right we found out that
um there's Jade and them their Hills
here in
California we got Jade here in
California we just found out uh I think
it actually might have been the same
person the same Emerald person was
saying it in the chat before the show
today so Emerald loosi bam Emerald bam
whatever happened to Emeral dude he's a
he's on Tik Tok no I'm just kidding no
he's still he's still dude you know
Emerald's still dude yeah um
check it out Ethan this is big news oh
boy oh boy uh wait a minute is it this
one which one is it there it is there he
is gently whoa wait hold on gently
sourced Jade
Califoria dude there's Jade here Farm
the table so hold on is this like what
kind of class of Jade are we talking is
this jadeite it's uh not jadeite um
although there may be some jadeite I saw
that it was mostly um
uh whatever the other one was here you
go nef nephite is actually oh they do
say ji too nephite is actually the
preferred one that's the nicer one I
thought ji was the more expensive
actually not nephite is uh the classic
kind of Chinese jade that you see
happily defer to your expertise they're
both Valu they're both highly valued
well you know what I'm excited to learn
about it on our field trip I'd really
love to do like Dan you'll appreciate
like a California gold segment like
someone dress up like Huer yeah you know
that'd be so like we all dress up like
hu Houser did you ever go on a field
trip uh if you grew up in Cali did they
ever take you to like on a gold field
trip yes we went to Sacramento yeah yeah
yeah yeah so fun we had like the little
fake pans yeah we fake nice uh Sam how
much longer do you need I'm just
wondering if I should do a little
segment here or wait for or if we're
ready to
go ready to start let's go Bringing out
this is very exciting folks love he
doesn't eat vegetables he
refuses they're not good he says why
don't you like vegetables love I don't
know people have been speculating a lot
uh I I did grow up being encouraged to
eat vegetables my mom loves vegetables
my dad does not like vegetables a he
likes a little bit more stuff than me so
I think it's mostly my dad's full uh but
also like I I get a physical response
like I mentally cannot eat a lot of
things it makes you feel nauseous no I
wouldn't say nause but like just my
whole existence goes against eating
certain things what is it you feel when
you put a vegetable in your mouth um
usually it's not the taste that's the
issue it's the the consistency usually
texture and and I'm very scared of the
mushroom that's on here the mushroom
that is mushroom mushrooms good
mushrooms are weird I agree it took me a
while to get to eat mushrooms they're
weird it's like Fung
a like a whole different life form but I
I like to try new things so I I I always
try something before I say I don't like
it just so people know I don't just
thank I'm going to eat along with thank
you so much this looks phenomenal we
need to get a shot of this this is
amazing so where's can we get a good
shot of this uh here AB you come grab so
I want also before we start I want um
Sam's guess about which on you're going
to like if Benny input now this is
asparagus have you tried asparagus
before uh Yes actually the first time I
tried it was at your house uh I think
your oh the barbecue yeah did you eat it
yeah so your mom put it on my my plate
and and since I was like I didn't cook
the food I'm at someone else's house I
ate it and I was like you know what this
is not bad it's been grilled with like
steak juice and all that so I was like
pretty good let me ask you this did you
eat a whole one I how much did you eat
like a couple bites couple bites of one
of one yeah but I would wouldn't eat it
again but here we
are here we are but this looks great Sam
uh real quick before we
start I wanted to get your predictions
on which dishes love you think will like
here what are your what are your
favorites you muted uh sorry I think
that love is really going to like the
candied yam
that's the last one and I think you
might like the stuffed mushroom see
stuffed mushrooms are good I'm feeling
confident about this bacon wrapped
asparagus so have we got a good shot of
it sorry I'm uh you can kind of see it
here I'm trying to get my uh little
remote camera setup you switch to love
real quick yeah okay
here second look at that man Sam that is
gorgeous sh don't you have a camera
handheld maybe yeah it's uh having an
issue oh it is okay I'm trying to that's
that's that's fair all right love let's
go ahead and go in for the bite that's a
10 all right let's go do I eat the shell
or do I eat the tree or the uh the it's
all it's all it's all equally Ed top
part wait okay no The Fluffy top Parts
where you eat
from I don't eat the the bottom of
asparagus oh it's fine it's too chewy
it's like it does get a little bit more
chewy but it's still totally edible it's
too sometimes it's inedible I can't fck
with it after you eat asparagus love
your urine smells uh interesting I've
heard yes very exciting yeah I guess
like this look at this like yeah I
don't think the other eat this show
me hello oh
sorry oh it's green yeah that so
listen this is bacon covered vegetable
it tastes i' rather eat the bacon alone
solo you know what I mean can you taste
the vegetable at all
tast listen listen here I can't
even that's what I'm saying I wouldn't
prepare I I I cut the bottom off just
cuz yeah I I just the flavor here is not
isue I feel bad that Sam cooked this cuz
she's basically Ted with a very
impossible
test you like bacon without bacon
because to me when I try this it's like
cooked in bacon grease wrapped in bacon
all I taste is
bacon that's
it
yeah very good delicious decent it is it
is i' said good it's good but you would
never choose to eat this no no no you
would just go for the bacon
alone yeah yeah that's like my
overwhelming thought right now I'm going
to try the other one too I'm going to
try the shell or the top
three the stuff that just melts in my
mouth where it's just one shoe there's
no resistance that stuff I'm fine with
but when I get down to the
Shel by the way not to I'm not trying to
say anything about Sam's cooking she's
incredible I was just saying I prefer to
cut the bottom off that's just a
preference oh true Sam is saying the
reheated messed the texture up but it
was great I mean it was delicious so
this one here is corn sule I can't say
I've ever had this mhm very exciting do
you like corn yeah so corn is one of the
things I do like so this will definitely
probably
M yo oh my that's crazy Good Sam oh my
what the hell yo you guys got to try
this that's insane Sam yeah bro it looks
so what the it's one of the best
things I've ever had in my life this is
delish dude I'm not even kidding you
guys got to try this this is like a mix
of um corn in the cob right cornbread
cornbread wow
damn you have enough for them to try
right I do dude you guys got to try this
uh I have Taco Bell on the way bro try
this so good I'm just kidding can I try
yeah I'm happy to try it I'm losing my
mind look at this I'm eating the whole
thing dude yeah that is exquisite what
the hell wa it wow okay I don't like
corn for the
record and this is stunning that bacon
is so delicious whatever you did with
that
bacon my
god wow okay well you like corn so that
was obvious M but wow Sam wow gorgeous
wow holy
n
coming out next is a iconic appetizer
that's been taking the World by storm
the
Buffalo broccoli oh thank you look at
that oh it's now Buffalo broccoli uh
love is it's breaded and fried broccoli
tossed in buffalo wing
sauce this is scary to me it's all good
just you can bite into it it's not like
the asparagus it's you the smell is very
strong let me take a bite and I'll see
that's a 10 good I'm honestly this one
like I dread I dread eating this the
sauce is kind of intense but the sauce
I'm also kind of scared of buffalo sauce
is pretty
intense Love's taking a
bite did you get even get any broccoli
or yeah he's having a bad reaction to
this that
I don't like that one bit tell me about
it walk me through the
[Music]
experience yeah I don't know what that
that is just too much
vegetable here we have a deep fried and
breaded vegetable doesn't get
more but the honestly the sauce is
overwhelming me too that is a
pretty when do you cut the Buffalo and
I'll hook you up what is this sauce you
use
Sam sweet baby rays this is sweet baby
rays sweet baby rays buffalo
sauce right so here's the thing love I
mean broccoli I'm sure you've heard is
one of the healthiest things you can eat
yes so it would be a real shame if we
couldn't find something broccoli related
for you now what I'm interested in is
what if we dry it grounded it up and put
it in Coke or
something yeah I don't think that's how
vegetables work I think you're supposed
to eat
it not processed to that level because I
don't think there'd be much cuz listen
I'm temporary like if I just had it or
maybe a shot maybe I should have a shot
and I just sometimes I put like powdered
veggies in my smoothies they do that I
like the idea of powder
yeah but I think honestly the biggest
issue in this dish is the sauce maybe if
I had a unsued one I have to agree I
have to agree that sweet baby Ray kind
of dropped the ball on the buffalo sauce
I think their I've had their buffalo
sauce I thought try this dude it's crazy
I will I will can so powerful here try I
have extra try
this itself is really
good the sauce is overwhelming okay that
is probably the strongest buffalo sauce
I've ever had this is a mushroom no I'm
oh this is oh this isn't stuffed
mushroom what the hell is this guys are
crazy that's bomb Oh you like it
okay so I guess it's a preference
thing crazy so this is spaghetti squash
dude look at this look what she made can
you
cut uh Focus really
blurry so in terms still really blurry
okay that's you see you get it and yeah
there you go okay we got it so in terms
of uh how to eat this Sam we just use
our fork and eat out of the middle right
all right love let's do it no you don't
eat the
skin you don't eat the skin you use a
fork how am I supposed I don't even know
what it what this is e eat up the center
all the the little spaghetti looking
stuff right so what is this again it's a
spaghetti squash and what's this and
what is this and perhaps what is the
inside like a Sam go ahead you want to
to tell love what he's dealing with yeah
he's
great this is amazing the whole ocean so
oh wow yeah just just dig in there in
the middle you know wait hold on hold
the fu it's a squash but it's spaghetti
oh so I need to know what the seasoning
is before I say I like it cuz maybe it's
something crazy it looks like bread and
Parmesan by guess there's uh Pinko
breadcrumbs a little bit of Parmesan
cheese Mozzarella cheese bread Crum and
bread olive oil I think that that's like
pretty much it oh time time is it's time
time is on your side love this is really
good Sam it's it's good um the parmesan
is very strong but listen this is
delicious all right I got to ask the the
viewers even though I think this is
delicious mentally I have a extremely
hard time even eating it just know
knowing what it's I don't like I think
you have honest to God there's some kind
of eating disorder I I I hesitate to say
that but there is something I think that
could probably be treated with some type
of therapy maybe because it seems like
you have an
irrational fear or an irrational uh
distaste cuz you you on one hand you
acknowledge this tastes good yeah but on
the other hand you're saying can't put
it in my mouth it just doesn't feel
right yeah I've I've thought the thought
that it might be something like that but
it's not it's not been a big issue in my
life cuz I don't eat it right but this
is delish I I'll say it I'm able to take
some more take another bite yeah um but
yeah mental mentally it's very
tough so would you you would you
wouldn't be able to eat this whole thing
no no no no no no it's good though I
will say and I'm so curious how this
fruit looks like it's just a squash and
then it's called spaghetti squash I've
never seen a squash I see a lot of
people in the chat uh spamming this word
afid which I'm assuming is a afraid no
no uh a a RFI D maybe look that up I'll
I'll look after was that a eating thing
I I I think so oh okay wow we we might
be having a breakthrough here love yeah
maybe how's it spelled
down uh Olivia just pulled it up
avoidant restrictive food food intake
disorder more commonly known as afid is
a condition characterized by the person
avoiding certain foods or types of food
having restricted intake in terms of
overall amount eaten or both someone
might be avoiding and or restricting
their intake for a number of different
reasons well that's pretty Broad and
yeah I mean that that sounds like what
you have or are doing or however you
want to describe it I don't know if yall
have watched like Freaky Eaters yeah I'm
you're you're that's not even comparable
no I feel what you're saying but like
when I a lot of L of those people are
like I can only eat this one thing cuz
everything else makes me feel so weird
huh
yeah really more
severe situation than than what you're
having but these look delicious what we
got here these mushroom stuffs here
let's get a good look at that ab's
coming over look at that mushroom
stuffed with cheese oh what is that
spinach yes oh damn those are
bomb who wouldn't be happy to pop one of
those in their mouth they love that look
good I smelled it I just smells kind of
good but it's just giving me shivers
cheers shim shiver Me Timber cheers my
dude cheers my dude m
m wow did you eat the whole thing no no
he took like a bite of it it's so creamy
and tasty isn't
it yeah I don't think I can SW that you
got to spit it out oh
no man damn I had hope for the for the
mushrooms I'm Big Time Mushroom game
okay that is weird I again nothing that
jumps out I don't like the sheiness
either but nothing that jumps out as
disgusting It's just tough here's what
I'll say mhm mushrooms even compared to
the whole vegetable Empire yeah is a
very odd texture it's just a weird ass
thing that's what I felt even when
picking it up yeah you know that being
said they can be absolutely delicious
and this is one of those times oh yeah
mhm you want to hit this Dan the the
stuffy the stuffy boy I'd love to thank
you um love since that one kind of hit
you rough why don't you take a bite of
the taco and clean your palet oh yeah I
got to hit the taco and guys that's good
right Good Sam yeah and and uh I
also am quite a good cook too I realized
if you ask the Taco Bell people to put
yapo sauce in your Taco Bell it makes
makes it so Good's
yellow Pino creamy sauce yellow Pino you
know said I I'm a pretty good cook too
you got me you got me D Love you're like
deep into Taco Bell lore that I don't
even know yeah the yellow Yello Oh no
I'm he's so right I often times ask for
a little side of it it's like the best
sauce they got to talk about is the best
the jalapeno yeah I guess I'm just not
in deep deep enough love eating his uh
cleanser right now
yeah the Dorito shell thank you so oh
that looks fantastic this I think I can
eat so this is a squash too love I don't
know if you know that this is a zucchini
really now and Italian squash if you
will oh this is the the fake cucumber
yes no no no it's not cucumber it's
squash it's different he's calling it
fake cucumber cuz they look the same
that I many times like o cucumber I love
cucum and then I eat it's like so squash
in my opinion especially zucchini is one
of the most approachable vegetables you
can eat cuz it's like soft it's chew
it's like really easy to eat it has a
really neutral flavor and this is one of
my favorite appetizers here it's just
breaded yeah
fried um zucchini that you dip in ranch
or very hopeful very hopeful listen go
bread Crum bread bread Crum yeah listen
this has the exact same concy as a fry
right or more or less right yeah close
this I with heavily all right okay
we got another winner but that's pretty
Good's healthy too like that's like a
good veggie to eat and incorporate into
your I mean listen if you're it's better
than not eating any veggies ever 100% we
got to get you the ve the zucchini fries
then by all means that's a 10 I think I
even like the taste of it it's not just
uh it's big it's not just tolerable yeah
I'm wondering it season is it seasoned
oh yeah probably heav so maybe
I'm heavily seasoned yeah probably and
what is this
Perhaps
Perhaps yeah yeah it's a little seasoned
it's a little
seasoned you're right I don't even taste
zucchini I don't taste zucchini at at
all at all that's why like let's try
this love remove the breading okay and
then you can e the zucchini
strip uh it's kind
of you it's not a very strong flavor B
like at all like it's it's fairly subtle
so the the way I see the it rip almost
even
already the like the texture I got a
clean bite there on the top I'll e it
right now mhm oh come on you got to
that's so small bu no I should can you
eat that whole thing
right can you eat that whole thing yeah
but I just took the the part I took it
off from and yeah that's fine yeah okay
okay we got a winner with zucchini yeah
I don't I love the con consistency but I
you know yeah Sam I don't know if you're
following but we may have had a
breakthrough with
zucchini and you know what we should do
Sam once we find if we find one he likes
we should Branch out to different power
levels zucchini we advanc the talent
treat let's see maybe we can treat your
uh eating disorder here eating disorder
here live in front of a live audience
that'd be great that'd be so sick today
we have here fried okra okay I need a
disclaimer for the fried okra go ahead
this is I did not personally make this
one I bought this one Frozen mine would
look way better and taste way better
than this m enough it's a very long
process to make fried okra fair enough
okay let me take a taste generally I'm
not a fan of okra in general but let me
try this and see I got to tell you I've
never I've never tried this before I
don't know what an okra is they eat a
lot in Israel and I Ela loves it and I
just it's not for me it's kind of a
Southern food too right Sam yes yeah
it's one of my it's my one of my
favorite vegetables I love it so much
but it yeah takes forever to make I
don't like that one I just don't like
okas you know and you didn't even cook
it so yeah yeah you can hate on this one
all you want I cook it so yeah that's
kind of B so are you able to swallow it
you took one Piece whole piece I'm just
shooting it you took a whole piece yeah
okay I mean I'll take a
little yeah wash it down with some Coke
Zero yeah good you want to take a bite
of the taco just in preparation that one
was rough I will be honest I don't know
if it tastes green I won't like it
that's just how it is if it tastes green
tast GRE I won't like it love is
clearing his palette with the Dorito
shell Taco Bell taco washing it down
with a diet uh Coke Zero again just to
reset diet please I'm seeing a lot of
okra haters in the chat so it seems like
you're not really alone in the it's a
controversial I guess how does it look
like oh crap they're just like little
they look like little jalapenos with
ridges you know I was going to say it
tastes like a yapo tame tame yapo it's
not a pepper though it's or maybe it is
I don't know if it's related kind of
looks like a pepper interesting I think
yeah it's a plant a bean is a bean
that's what Sam's saying huh h a legume
if you will oh I guess I see that oh
I see what you're saying yeah so
this is
okra it's a bean and I don't know what
to say I it's just not it's just not my
I might yeah I don't the consistency
when it was cooked not very good maybe
if it's raw maybe I would like it more I
don't know you got a raw oakr
uh oh man I'd love to put that you
remember um since you were talking about
World of Warcraft earlier you guys
remember collecting okra in the in
Westfall for the farmers Quest oh you're
right yeah fun that's my main exposure
to Okra so that's what I always think of
when uh what C you talking about the
world of warc I don't remember I don't
very specific quest in the westall
region yeah I totally remember where you
collect okra I have not collected okra
in the Westfall that I I think you
probably have did you play alliance I
was hoard oh you were ho so maybe every
day I didn't with those guys got it
God got dude we used to be dude we used
to be hardcore we would we had a whole
group of paladins cuz you know how you
could go invulnerable for like 30
seconds and we would charge into the
human City just the with them dude
that's crazy and then we teleport out in
unison SS sick I remember doing that
raiding wow raing the towns hell yeah so
um okay I got to tell you there's a
bunch of people in the chat that know
exactly what I'm talking about yeah some
reason that Quest has embedded itself in
my mind from 25 years ago you know I
think they actually made a new Quest so
I don't think it's there anymore oh sad
I think they changed it sad damn that's
a shame but man this freaking uh corn
thing you're going back to that did you
try it I haven't had a chance to yet no
shot it's so good about I mean I'm I'm
switching the show right now okay thank
you give it a shot got a lot going on
and perhaps perhaps do know what sauce
this is I I made it it's a uh lemon
rosemary she says it's a lemon lemon
rosemary
aoli that's I I like aoli a lot thank
you Sam so this is the final one and
this is one that Sam has high hopes for
this is the candied yam can you describe
the process of of a is this mic on
Dan go ahead okay um so have you ever
had like a sweet potato same thing as
sweet potato pretty much um but you cut
them put them in a dish and make a sauce
and pour it over and then you bake them
and it gets all like emulsified M so I
do I do already like sweet potato you do
yeah oh okay you already have a head
really yeah it's a great I thought it
was unhealthy cuz it's so sweet I think
people say sometimes potatoes unhealthy
I think that has more to do with how
it's prepared but is heavily carved but
but sweet potatoes is is a very very
nutritious now what is this seasoning
perhaps uh it's candied right so sugar
it tastes like
Christmas it's uh butter sugar cloves
cloves almond milk that's that is very
Christmasy that combination so cinnamon
wow oh cinnamon that's it's cinnamon too
that's delicious that is just such a
little sweet
treat you ate the whole thing yeah I
this PL this I I would f such a little
sweet so I actually think this is this
is a valuable exercise
because I do think it's important for
you to start considering to eat
vegetables more frequently and if you
can get in the habit of eating more
sweet potato or
zucchini then maybe once you get more
used to eating those kinds of dishes you
might be able to open open up a little
more I think it's about my mental
barrier and if I can break slowly break
that down by ramping into it yeah I
think so yeah do you
feel that you want to be able to enjoy
vegetables or do you not
care I don't really care you don't care
no
no you don't you don't now sometimes
when like Dan is ordering a Brey burrito
I'm like it's not even worth it for me
to like usually I can take it and take
that out and take that out but breakfast
burrito I don't like cheese I don't like
all these vegetables I don't
like all these vegetables in a breakfast
burito I know sometimes it's one I get
has I get a I get a veggie breakfast
burrito he's vegetarian I know that love
right you don't have to get a veggie
burrito you could get like a bacon
potato burrito always gets a steak one
dude yeah they go crazy in those
breakfast but it's egg cheese and like
Peppers those I don't if you don't like
egg then that's a it's a nonstarter
breakfast burrito is not your game
exactly so in a sense there there's the
place where I like I wish I was a little
bit open open minded I like Dan was
touching on there will be a day someday
when a doctor is going to sit you down
and tell you
listen got to start eating more V right
cuz you'll just generally feel like
because you're going on 30 and it's
going to be like what about your diet
and you're going to be like I eat
nothing but Taco Bell and he's going be
like that's probably why you feel like
but until then but until then have
fun absolutely enjoy your youth as
Mongol is doing good what does that mean
he started eating vegetables no he
doesn't is even been just like me oh is
he doing good he's doing great what does
he eat his usual Sim very similar to
myself fast food he likes Wendy's
right I'm I'm the same way I I'm okay so
far but we'll see well we just eating
like all the time you yeah all the
time oh well you exercise regularly
though no I know I think that does make
a difference help I haven't since the
Creator Clash really oh wow are you
gaining weight no I've actually been
losing weight oh really yeah cuz of the
muscle mass you think muscle mass and
just sleeping better oh you're sleeping
better that's nice cuz when I'm up like
super long I'm eating more as well like
super late which is
rough we got weight so you you also have
an issue eating vegetables AB I I don't
hate them no I don't hate them but I
don't eat them a lot right yeah fast
food so what I'd like to do love with
your consent I can keep
them is to build upon what we've what
we've done
here yeah and uh you know Branch out
into the world of squashes Branch out
into the world
of of
uh what was the other one you liked
sweet potatoes sweet potato yeah
potatoes I like a lot I like potato like
a skill tree and an MMO yeah it's like a
talet tree you just Branch out right so
I do you like potato potato yeah not
fried like just potato well I'm Swedish
so it's a lot of cooked potato boiled
okay that's good they with those
potatoes that's good cuz you can prepare
sweet potato and potato pretty much the
same way yeah
mhm I'm I'm excited I I'm hopeful this
is very hopeful development in The Saga
yeah of Love's life I did fear that he
was just going to outright reject all of
them but we had what there was like
three that you were outright like this
is great like not even just like okay
but potato uh the zucchini zucchini is
like wasn't it was or like yeah pretty
good right I guess um corn corn I love
I'm a big corn boy I love any corn wel
to America except love corn here boy I
like cold corn I don't love warm co co
corn that much wait what he doesn't like
warm corn Dan actually my son's the same
way cuzz when Teddy wants it and I cut
it I cut it in strips down and it all
sticks together in one strip he loves
that keep on dancing Love Bug H yeah
partner Keep on
Dancing very very good well boys that's
it for here today we love me some corn
out here in America love keep going keep
doing it love Keep on Dancing Keep
dancing come on it's a square dance F
come on now dance more piggy now sque
piggy dance sque now you got to look
happier with while you do it come on now
pigga
Smile Smile boy come on show say pearly
[Music]
W I used to work
uh one of the jobs I had when I was in
college was at like this weird light
fixture
store and the owner was real like an old
dude and he used to he was such a
uh old school chauvinist he
would he would talk to the the women who
work there and be like hey here comes a
guy give him a smile brighten up his day
Stu like that being like hey there's a
guy over there go go over there and give
him a
smile that sounds like some old school
that sounds like our friend who
makes people's days better at Trader
Joe's yeah right right Zach does that on
a daily basis he does he goes over there
comparing me to a chauvinistic well no
you're more no no what he told e to do
is give a smile right you're the one
giving the smile the
your heart I know what you mean though
Zach I was feeling yeah that's a dish
right there wait I don't know if I was a
fa she met your modern day sh you know
what you can take my words however you
will I was just saying you brighten
people's day and th that's the wording
that you well sounds nice you have a
beautiful smile and you have a stunning
smile that sounds nice but kind of cve
she she's amended her statements Zach
yeah cheer up the audience a little bit
can you uh give us a smile baby
what are you doing thank you there it is
that was what I was talking about hey
there's some ladies in the audience give
them a smile Z right up you do have a
great smile though thanks thanks B well
there it is that was a a really exciting
journey through vegetables world and
yeah better than I expected yeah thank
you very much Sam that was very very
shout out Sam ni can you tell I love
vegetables
I yeah I got my veggie phone girl loves
veggies is that a veggie Q too let me
say this yes it is a veggie what now wow
Cy oh let me say this I think the goal
ultimately in this project is to see if
we can get you to eat a healthy version
of the vegetable and those exist you
know just the right spice but then also
to see if we can get you to eat like a
serving of it not a lot right but just
like a serving which is like a small
plate a tiny plate full
right yeah I mean no problem say damn
that sounds a lot right no it's and
don't don't get anxious it's a lofty
goal right I believe in him I it's a
good goal it's a good goal I believe
we'll see a day where love will eat
asparagus not wrapped in bacon he'll
just eat it wow wow I believe in it dude
I believe in it three pieces of broccoli
of
asparagus without any transportation
help like a bacon you can like like what
how I made it pan fry a little right
right right you know you know what's a
great way to have asparagus and you said
earlier that you love this is you just
put a ton of garlic with it
that's true mm oh sometimes I you love
garlic so you can M that with the
garlic nothing wrong with garlic so I'm
I'm blind pilled to the point where I
see like someone in the office
eat a salad and I was like no
shot you like that
you're yeah yeah you did I call it
virtual
signal signaling it's like no shot you
eat that that is brown pill you're
or black brown P that's like men going
their own going their own way without
vegetables we do not need vegetables
that's how hard of a time I have to
accept that people like it yeah I mean
salads can be delicious obviously it's
like do you L does it taste as good as
like a hamburger it doesn't but it it's
it's enjoying in a different way cuz
it's a wholesome it's refreshing you
don't feel heavy and there's some really
delicious salad dressings frankly too
it's all about the dressing at the end
of the day absolutely absolutely Absolut
which I know you understand as a sauce
boy look I I love sauce I loveing is
just sauce for salad dressing up and
then I mean you can mix it up with like
olives dressing up with croutons
croutons you I love croutons I know you
don't like cheese so I would never
suggest that love says Crouton Crouton
that's that's probably the real way to
say it probably close what you mean real
way to say it Crouton Crouton yeah well
like the French right in Swedish we say
cronon cron the real way to say it the
French way here let's get it
pronounciation Crouton Crouton Crouton
yeah I love garlic though I will say
will you eat whole roasted garlic yeah
for sure that's good Crouton Crouton
according to Google it's
that's like the most American ass sound
cronon Crouton Crouton that's Google
Crouton
cre Crouton how to pronounce it in
French let's
see
Crouton Crouton okay Crouton Z couton I
like this one Crouton Crouton that's
like the most American ass dumb sounding
English
Crouton it's a
crouton there it is case adill
quesadilla oh wait speaking which the
the Taco Bell show up they've already
filled us this they it's wrong it's on
the table No it started in the middle of
a they came in the middle of the segment
oh okay was here well let's get that
going well hell doll no but this I
I enjoy this I do I do I've never I've
always tried things I I always give
things a sha and um this was very
enlightening and very nice we love that
we love that all right well very good
thank you
everybody see I'm I'm trying to be nice
let's see we've got lots of other stuff
to get to one thing I do want to mention
at the top of the show here top of the
show it's we're at two hours right
that's not exactly true I was looking at
the top of the show section like
document and that that's just not true
at all I want to once again remind
everyone what a benevolent uh
generous uh uh
altruistic person I am oh just in case
we forgot I don't know if everyone
remember but I did donate $6,500 to the
Palestinian medical assistant hosted by
Hassan and don't want anyone to
Forget You Know Dearborn Legend
right here thanks bro we need a new
video of this
yeah um so thas I want to I have to talk
about
something some of yall might not like it
but I'm so I'm going to do it
fast about the allegations okay stop I
think it's important to say so that's
why I want to do this it's about
something we were talking oh my God this
is funny cam this is so cursed love you
pick the road which one you to walk
down the choice is pretty clear to me
yeah damn dude them with the meat scarf
is so up that is crazy God the
meat scarf is he's sick man I will say
as of now if I were to be a vegetarian
or a
meitian I I have to pick the meat cuz I
cannot sustain a life on just veggies at
the moment well I don't think anybody
can for the record they eat lots of
other stuff he doesn't just eat
vegetables eat I don't just eat
vegetables yeah what you but I mean some
I mean I'm not vegan I'm just vegetarian
there are vegans you eat eggs right yeah
I I I got protein based yeah I mixed it
up yeah right okay so maybe I could pick
that so if you are take if you're choose
Thank you so much if you're uh forced to
walk one of these paths it would be of
meat Kings Pro man I I wish there wasn't
wasn't a face on there cuz I would pick
Dan just because he's there oh well
thank you man cuz I can't go with him
but if it was just meat or Salad I'd
have to pick
me that makes sense all right so anyway
um anyway yesterday we had see you next
Tuesday which we did for the
members it was a fun time thank you for
being
there one thing is that the news was
breaking I think I'm sure everybody's
heard about this by now this huge story
that's uh a hospital in
Gaza the story story was that the IDF
air stried the
hospital killing at least
500 and it was so I mean I was in so
much despair from that story I think
everyone was just like wow this this is
horrible and I was just praying like
please I don't want this to be true cuz
the ramifications for this would be
terrifying I mean just in the middle of
the night in Lebanon and other countries
they were rioting SL
protesting uh outside us and Israeli
embassies and the risk of this thing
getting escalated into a larger war is
very real and very very very scary and
this is the type of thing that could
escalate it
so I was uh arguing with some people in
chat and once I think the biggest
takeaway of from this uh that everyone
needs to bear in mind is to please
listen to me
more uh before you get more into this
I'm sorry real quick my uh my cat is
actually stuck in a tree so I I have to
go I'll be right back though before free
your cat is stuck in a tree yeah yeah I
got to go I'll I'll be right back but
continue oh he's going to rescue his cat
you
guys what a hero wow you sure it's not a
small child on the
freeway I don't believe so okay yeah
he's gone he's out of
here
I think he just did a Shaquille O'Neal
delete me from this conversation which
again I understand because let's be real
we've talked about this no matter what
your opinion is there's somebody out
there that's going to hate your
guts for thinking it and I think that's
part of
what created this situation that was so
volatile
because at first yesterday afternoon the
story broke and the immediate reaction
from the media
the media at large frankly it's pretty
incredible looking back they all ran
this headline IDF air strikes Hospital
killing 500 that is horrible but
uh so I understand why people are
getting worked up and you know that's
just that's just
horrible and uh the thing I guess is
that the IDF started to deny it they
said that it was the result of a
Palestinian jihadist of Palestine so it
wasn't even uh Hamas that did it
although it was another terrorist group
in in in
Gaza and
so there was a lot of speculating there
was a lot of fiery
opinions uh on both
sides and you know my takeaway when I
was doing the live was let's just
let's just wait and see before we you
know are trying to rile up a massive
escalation of
War cuz that that's what was on the line
this was a big
deal so you know just remember guys it
costs nothing to wait it's free to
wait you don't have to draw a conclusion
immediately
that's you know what I mean like that's
really a noble thing just just wait a
little bit you know and so as more time
went on more evidence started coming out
that supported uh the IDF statement that
they did not air strike it including
some really compelling videos
of
um I have the videos I don't know if you
guys want to watch them they're they are
pretty interesting cuz I was I was just
glued to the to the internet yesterday
just trying to figure out like what the
happened here you know cuz it was
scary and I I would if the is if Israel
really did this I mean there that would
just be way that would just
be you know hell to pay for
that um so the first thing that happened
and this broke yesterday afternoon these
guys Geo
confirmed who I understand is extremely
reputable these guys actually do
something really interesting
it's managed by volunteers these people
who are like obsessed with maps and
coordinates and stuff and they've been
doing a ton of work in the UK in Ukraine
not the Ukraine excuse me
Ukraine to track where Rockets are being
fired from because there's a lot of
disinformation there about like
sometimes Ukraine is shooting mortars or
rockets and it's hitting their own
people and they're blaming Russia and
vice versa and so these guys don't
appear to have any kind of political
slant
and so when this came out it I it was it
was quite a compelling thread they said
uh a missile launched by Palestinian
groups exploded midair one of the pieces
fell onto the hospital's yard you got to
kind of give it up to these guys that's
it that's from what I understand now
exactly what happened and these guys put
this tweet out at 2 p.m yesterday when
everybody including pop the mainstream
media was saying Israel did this so
these guys really put their neck out
there in a crazy way and they were that
that's exactly what happened we're
understanding they even have like the
exact coordinates these guys are really
something the really interesting uh so
here you go full recording the rocket is
intercepted in the air breaks apart
shrapnel there was one really
interesting wrinkle is
that Al jazer was doing a live broadcast
and just
incidentally the rocket was caught
behind them on the live and you can see
it exactly but that that this these are
all confirmed videos too there was a
whole lot of misinformation
about um oh it's old footage and which
is true there was an old clip that was
going
around but I want to emphasize that
these are all real Clips these are all
confirmed so you can see a rocket went
up the theory is it had a malfunction
split apart the Warhead falls to the
ground as well as like the rocket head
and uh it fell right there which is just
a tragic
accident
uh and I'm relieved to say that I it was
Mo looking like right now almost
certainly not the IDF and I think
everybody should be relieve relieved to
know that you know and keep keeping
again the keeping the plight of the
Palestinians at the Forefront of our
mind about what they're going through
and the amount of unimaginable death
thousands of death that is happening
there is happening there as a result of
this
IDF um military
operation but the reason it's the truth
is important again is
because this risks a massive
escalation and I think we can all that
is not something any of us want to
happen so I think uh I think it's
important that everybody just take a
minute and just we must have cooler
heads prevail yesterday when I was doing
the live I was like let's just wait and
see I was looking over the evidence and
I was like this looks like IDF I have to
say like I don't understand how this was
a rocket I don't understand it
but I said let's just wait and see as
information comes out and even that
alone
is is offensive to a lot of people
people in the audience people in the
chat and I I
just again the plet keeping bearing in
mind the what's actually happening there
the truth is important about how this
stuff happens and it doesn't make Israel
innocent and everything else right but
it does matter it does matter to
understand what actually
happened um when I saw video clips of
like uh people riding in in Lebanon
outside the con the uh embassies I was
like this is horrible this is
going to be War there were there was
like shots of tons of people driving out
to the US Embassy just in the middle of
the night this was like 2:30 a.m. they
were all driving out there and it looked
like and people were understandably
angry and I can't even blame them for
even thinking that because simply the
the mainstream media was reporting that
headline like uncritically which is
pretty
incredible yeah here's the clip I saw
Lebanese uh protesters are headed to the
US Embassy after the bombing of gaza's
hospital so you know I saw this and I
was like oh dude this is they're
going to want to go to
war and again
totally understandable the reaction
based on the headlines that were going
out
um this guy's
thread these guys are really incredible
it's their their Pro work process is
actually just really incredible to look
at here they like look at the pictures
line them up with coordinates to try to
triangulate exactly where the explosion
hit making exactly where the rocket fell
and uh these guys really are
incredible um going down I want to show
you guys the AL jazer one is this the
one here or is this a different
one you you see this from a few
different
angles and when I saw this you know I
was like well maybe Israel didn't
do
this
yeah um the AL Zer one was the one that
really convinced me like damn this this
I don't think this was it and then the
other confusing thing was that people
reporting 500 plus I start even to see
people saying upwards to a thousand
people died which again is really
horrible and scary but then when when
the morning came
around
um and pictures started to emerge from
the the
scene uh hold on yeah they're just
they're just talking about how they
locate the
uh the right
thing I mean these guys are in the weeds
doing all this crazy
uh here's a surveillance footage
from a barrage of Rick of rockets I
don't know if this one shows that one
that that we're talking
about um where's this Al jaer one Jesus
Christ so far down here but this is
important the next day
um pictures started to
emerge first of all this is this looks
horrible but what actually happened is
that the rocket the Warhead that the
explosion it happened in the parking lot
the hospital in fact wasn't even damaged
as far as I'm aware as far as I've
understand it the hospital was is not
damaged so I do think what happened was
that like a there was people that
definitely were tragically killed who
are in the parking lot but again this
number of 500
just I mean it is I guess it's it is
possible if there was I
mean I guess it's I guess it's possible
it just it seems very
unlikely and another thing to bear in
mind when you're taking in all this
media is that the person the people that
reported this missile attack and the
deaths is Hamas now I'm not saying
everything Hamas says is well let me put
it this way if I hear any news out of
Hamas or
Israel I'm not taking either one of
those at face value I feel like you need
to wait for some
International reputable reporting to
confirm because they both have an
extremely vested interest and
uh you
know prop propagandizing I don't know if
that's if I said that right people to uh
their
cause that's just a fact but I do you
know so so bear in mind that 500 number
is is reported from
Hamas and it usually is when you read a
newspaper and it says um Palestinian
officials said Hamas is they're the
officials of of Gaza
or gazen officials whatever so that's
just something to bear in mind there
um and the reason I say this again is
because I want
to where the is that alga zero one
damn oh this was a really weird one the
IDF put this out I I'll just play it for
you and then we can talk about it but as
people were trying starting to piece the
the puzzle together the IDF put out this
alleged recording of Hamas
operatives uh it's translated so if
you're
listening essentially they're just
talking about that there was an accident
that the Missile hit the uh the hospital
and uh they just seem like oh
[Music]
for and then they go on to say that they
shot the rocket from the cemetery right
behind the hospital and that pretty much
I believe has been confirmed as well
which is again something to bear in mind
here um now this is again this came from
IDF so this could very well not
be you know it's far
from Super
credible but it is interesting
especially in the context of everything
that we've now
learned uh but again like I said it's
it's coming from Israel so it's not not
enough credibility there to say one way
or the
other um let me see trying to find this
Al jazer video maybe someone can find it
cuz I don't know I thought it was in
this
thread
um here
is let me
see but anyway the listen
again what is happening in Gaza is
disgusting and it needs to stop
immediately and I put my money where my
mouth is okay I donated $6,500 to the
Palestinian the gazen fund to help them
to help the civilians
there but I do think it's very important
for everybody who's following this
story to keep their heads cool
to try your best it's difficult in these
times to stay you know levelheaded and
rational and just like you
know thoughtful it doesn't help anyone
to jump to conclusions like this and by
the
way I'll say this this media frenzy of
misreporting what happened from popular
media all the way down to you know
influencers lefties everyone was just
full on this happened dude there
couldn't be a better gift to the IDF
now like you don't understand
how people are going
to now IDF has this plausible
deniability on any on
anything it's
like you know
they'll say it wasn't us and they were
right after they got blamed by the whole
media and now it's like they have this
whole thing to fall back on and say yeah
it's like the best gift ever to Israel
the hysterical coverage of this and I
don't mean hysterical to because it was
horrible right hysteria is not a nice
word the passion was warranted I want to
make that clear passion was
warranted just had of curiosity did
anyone ever follow up with why those two
tweets were
deleted uh in regards I think Israel put
one out and then another one was from uh
I believe he's head of head of something
I forget the the title he Has so I don't
know there that was like the two main
evidence I saw people saying as proof
that it was IDF MH which let's be real
it's not that that's pretty thin you
guys one of them was a was like an IDF
spokesperson who put out a video saying
that like yeah it was Israel that bombed
the hospital and then he he erased it
pretty soon after he's just some random
guy who no he's not a random guy
he represents the government but he
erased it he was wrong just one guy he
was wrong he said he saw the media
headlines and just assumed that it was
Israel and then the other one that was
erased
was uh I don't remember what it was it
was uh from as an analysis with the
video right they erased it I don't know
why they erased that one but the thing
is at this point it's been confirmed by
the Pentagon by Independent by media
sources that this was the
failed this was the malfunction of a of
a rocket attack by the
uh
um the Islamic uh jihadist of
Palestine but I you know I saw a lot of
people bringing those up and what and I
agree it's weird but it's hardly proof
you know what I mean in the face of all
of the mounting
evidence that we've now come to
see that basically all but in my it
really all but shows that this was a
tragic accident uh here's here's a shot
from the air in the morning
of there was lots of like you
know it's a shame some of the media you
see and again I don't blame you because
there was a video of something hitting a
building
uh and a huge explosion I don't I don't
know where was that was from or if it
was from this
event but what happened was here you can
see I think people started to really
come
around to Israel's didn't do it is this
morning when they
surveyed the blast area here's the
parking lot this is where the Warhead
hit and you can see the results is
basically there was a there was you know
maybe a dozen cars that caught on fire
there but the damage was
um it
was just in the parking lot and then the
the other thing that is that I think
is kind
of uh
explanatory if I can pull this up is the
there was another one that said
um that showed the uh the
crater and there's a lot of uh it shows
the crater there's pretty much no crater
at all it's like a little dent in the
ground which is not at all consistent
with an Israeli uh air
strike so I'm trying to find that crater
too did anyone find the AL Zer one I
don't know I can't find
that
can anyone look for that
thanks oh here's the impact crater here
this is what I was trying to say so this
this is the impact
Creator
and look I'm not I'm not a a military an
analy so clearly I have no idea
but from what I'm hearing is that an
Israeli
missile is going to weigh tons
especially one that's going to blow up a
hospital and kill 500 people and it's
going to going to leave like a fairly
significant crater in the
ground you know and that to me looks
like not that big of a of a
crater
um thank you thank you so much here I
got oh these were the ones that were
deleted okay so this was uh so this is
the guy I was talking about he's part of
some I honestly don't know who he is he
tweeted out Israeli Air Force struck a
homos terrorist base inside of a
hospital and Gaza multiple number of
terrorists are dead it's heartbreaking
that Hamas launches Rockets from
hospitals first of all this guy's take
is insane like what he say is
happening is he saw the headlines and
then immediately rushed to Twitter to
say like there's a bunch of terrorists
that are dead he's he was talking about
500 people at the time
presumably that died in a hospital so
like this tweet is barbarous on
its
own but this guy is not representative
of the entire
Israeli uh intelligence apparatus
there's just some guy who was wrong you
know what I mean this one was uh Israel
tweeted out breaking news from the an
analysis of the operational system of
the IDF and an enemy rocket barrage was
carried out towards
Israel uh according to intelligence so
they put out this post and they erased
it I don't know why they erased it but
I'll tell you this there's tons of
verified footage of it happening I don't
know what was in this video or why they
erased it but we don't need these videos
to know what happened because there's
tons of videos from tons of different
perspectives including the what I'm
trying to find you guys the live
broadcast that was
just um incidentally found you can't
find it it was Al jazer was doing a live
report and you could just see the rocket
in the back it was just totally uh
random a random encounter
and it lines up perfectly with the time
it lines up perfectly with the
location this guy who this guy here who
deleted his tweet he's a leading Israeli
Jewish
influencer and human rights activist in
the fight against anti-Semitism anti-ms
and the BDS movement so I don't even
know if he is a working as of
official
spokesman he is he
is
oh he is a digital Aid to the Israeli
Prime Minister so he's a digital Aid
again
insane and
incriminating if we didn't have more
evidence this is OB this is clearly just
one monsterous freak you know
what I mean uh this one again here did
you find it the aler one uh this is I
believe this is it I mean it's not yeah
this is it this is it thank you um so
this is the one I saw where I was like
oh cuz you can clearly see what's
happening you clearly know the date the
time who's it was that it wasn't altered
or you know manipulated in any way so
here is the
report actually I'm just going to skip
to the end because it's kind of long and
it happens uh at towards the back but
you can see there's a couple missiles
launched and then right back here is
when see I don't even think this is the
one there just to show that they there
was there was Rockets being launched at
the
[Music]
time go
ahead go ahead
now any
minute thanks
[Music]
x x
x what what
happened may try to refresh the
page drum roll
[Music]
please here's one rocket I don't believe
this is the one comes after
this this
so what they it separated there was a
malfunction where the Warhead got
separated
from the rocket
body and again it's important to bear in
mind this does happen it's it's
approximated that 10% of the Rockets
shot from Gaza malfunction and they
frankly sadly they do end up coming down
and hitting uh public spaces in Gaza I
mean that's just only that's just only
natural so this stuff does
happen and there it is so again this is
all happening live on Al jaaz which is
such a crazy coincidence but one more
time you see the rocket and this has all
been geolocated right these guys they've
crunched the location the time
everything adds up goes the
rocket it's not intercepted in
malfunctions
sep to the
ground another thing that had me
skeptical was like I just don't know how
a rocket had such a big explosion it
doesn't make sense to me well one is
that it actually wasn't that it wasn't
as big as people thought uh based on the
scene from the parking lot and two this
was one of their like super long range
rockets and it was just launched so
presumably it had a ton of fuel in
it that was not used and so I think
that's part of what contributed to the
the size of the fire plume that comes up
from there
um so yeah
uh again I don't know if you trust
American Media if you trust the
president but Biden said that the
Pentagon independently confirmed
separately that it was uh a
malfunctioned rocket from the
Palestinian
uh jihadist group or whatever they're
called
um so you know basically my point is
just that this stuff does matter that's
it that's all I want to I want people to
say because the amount of people that
just were
immediately
um and vem and like not only they not
I'm wrong and also I'm I'm wrong for
saying let's wait all I said was like
let's just wait a little bit and that's
up apparently to some
people because again to me the this is
great news as sad as that's to say cuz
people did die but it's great news that
the idea first of all didn't kill 500
people probably didn't blow up a
hospital the hospital still there and
that they didn't intentionally bomb a
hospital and I'm not saying they
didn't do it but what was being reported
was horrific
and could have possibly brought other
people into the
war so I do think this is important and
I do think people especially in these
high tensions when everybody you know
was rushing to social media and wanting
to get the scoop on the story
that we have to be more levelheaded we
have to be and just H just you know
clear minds must Prevail weakest
analysis I'm sorry to tell you
but what's your analysis that two tweets
were erased that's your proof your proof
is that two tweets were erased I mean
these are the same people that look at
the the death scene of a murdered child
and say that the picture's face cuz
there's a fake there's a splatter of
pink on
it so
listen I see Jade chat I appreciate that
guys uh there's no leftovers on Thursday
I just wanted to touch on this because I
think it's important now again Israel
has bombed hospitals and I'll even say
this we looked into this report that
apparently something hit that hospital
even a few days ago that very
hospital and injured people people you
know so like I totally understand why
people drew this conclusion I understand
it I understand why so on one hand I'm
not even blaming people necessarily I am
blaming the the mainstream media it was
crazy that they ran with this headline
that wasn't
true but I don't blame influencers and
stuff that rushed out to to cover
it because like I said there there was
like a history of the IDF hitting this
Hospital right and combined with like
some of the footage and stuff I saw to
me my my first thought was this was
1,00% the idea for
sure but turns out that almost certainly
at this point it was a failed rocket
launch and that to me is worth saying
and it's
worth uh knowing the truth and this
isn't to absolve Israel of any of the
war crimes that they've done of which
there is a
lot but I don't know if you guys were
online the the atmosphere was
crazy online like after it was initially
reported about the uh 500 people in the
in the hospital being blown up like the
atmosphere was really it was scary I was
scared um what media did that literally
everyone it was like the BBC The
Washington Post Reuters it was it was
quite quite a significant amount of
people Ethan this is extremely painful
to hear well I'm if I'm sorry that it's
painful to you that uh the IDF didn't
kill a bunch of people in that hospital
my condolences to
you you're spreading propaganda Ethan
you're a
you're
you dude you're stuck you're in a
propaganda hole like literally you fell
to Hamas propaganda you you you're
you're spreading the propaganda of a
terrorist
organization because two two tweets were
erased there's like almost no evidence
at this point at all that points to the
IDF
none so I understand that you're con
you're convinced that this happened I
understand that you think I'm like a
monster or
something but uh to me the truth matters
and I don't want this war to escalate
and I'm scared scared for the people in
Gaza and I'm scared for the people in
Israel and this war and I don't want
this war embarrassing yourself I mean
listen just go read a little tiny bit
you know what I
mean I don't know what to tell you it's
all there it's all
there true you know and there's there
seems to be a lot of people that are
angry that Israel didn't didn't blow up
the hospital and
kill uh 500 civilians they're angry that
it didn't happen and I express my
deepest condolences to
them uh that uh it didn't happen like
that so I'm very sorry
that but that being said obviously my
heart is always with the uh gazin the
Palestinians and I'm donating and I'm
rooting and I'm supporting them but the
truth ultimately is important if you
think I'm doing propaganda if you think
I'm lying um that's
fine but I must tell you the all the
evidence is out there if you want to
look and and read it and get into it now
and look at the U the footage from the
day after from this morning which is
essentially what really turned people
when they saw the the scene from this
morning
then if you don't want to look at that
and you just want to say it was IDF
because there was two erased tweets
then uh I'm afraid that you actually
might be succumb to Hamas propaganda
again the deaths the damage it was all
reported by Hamas I don't think Hamas or
IDF is a
reliable reporter of the
news uh and if you think otherwise on
either side then you're being pretty
pretty
obus I'm sorry some of yall don't want
me to talk about this I think it's
important it's important to me so there
it is that's all I have to say I I
genuinely I think it's important to say
that's
it thank
you uh Ethan is not lying he's just
playing too fast and loose with Twitter
propaganda again listen I encourage you
to just go
read like go outside your bubble of
people that are in this Perpetual state
of and Justified right because there are
horrible things
happening but I encourage you go read
this thread from geoc confirms you know
go look at the pictures and go look at
the media I mean even the media is
reporting it now like I saw on BBC BBC
was saying that it was likely now a a
rocket
strike so if you think I'm wrong I don't
I don't know what to tell you but
um the truth is important and regardless
of what you think if I'm right or wrong
let's say let's say we don't
know my point is even this let's all let
cooler Minds Prevail it's way too
important right now to be making claims
that we're not sure of so let's say
Ethan you're lying you don't know okay
but there's enough Reasonable Doubt at
this point to say maybe it
was a Mis A malfunctioned rocket so if
we can agree on that at least then we
can all agree like let's just wait and
find out wait for more uh you know uh
bipartisan reporting and investigation
and Analysis which is coming
out and
um so then we we agree and that was my
point from the beginning let's just be
patient it costs nothing to wait and
these things matter they are
important thank you there's also you
know and and I'll just tell you how the
stuff matters I mean a synagogue in
Germany was attacked
yesterday and I'm it was because of this
Hospital bombing story Berlin synagogue
attacked an anti-semitic incidents rise
you know it it's because and this
matters you know it does
matter I mean it matters to
me it should matter to you I think the
truth should matter but anyway my heart
and mind is always with the Palestinian
people the people of Gaza and uh always
working for the government to
stop thanks that's it any
thoughts anyone want to touch
that a
nightmare a nightmare
a nightmare a nightmare a
nightmare we encourage you to go read
other sources than us and Israeli media
dumbass go to any go to Reuters
go to BBC they're all saying it
morum I mean by the way the Israeli
media are the ones that are like most
critical of the Israeli government by
the way if you want to talk about
Israeli media go ahead it sorry no
you're good uh yeah I don't want to get
too into it but
like you said I think I agree with your
your point that people shouldn't jump to
conclusions but also as you said you
could see why some people were quick to
believe it because it's happened in the
past uh that's why and I believe it's
important to this is something I'm
working on and hopefully something I'm
getting better at I want to give people
more benefit of the doubt and treat
people more
charitable this hospital was attacked
before there was also apparently a
warning shot outside there they were
told to evacuate so
like understandable conclusion and like
I said that was my initial conclusion as
well so all I'm saying if I'm right or
if I'm wrong let's just wait and see so
that we don't uh you know cause World
War II is that okay can we not cause
World War
I I would prefer not
to but maybe I'm
crazy
um thank you very
much that Pierce Morgan interview with
uh Bassam Yousef that's going super
vital has 10 million views already it
was pretty that thing is very good that
guy's pretty funny man
yeah what is Piers Morgan Tak he's a
conservative back right like he's
got to be Pro he he brings in uh I mean
I don't know I'm not familiar but he
brings in what's his name the head of
the daily wire at the end of the
interview uh beno's partner what's his
name Jeremy Jeremy boring oh oh yeah he
had been on recently too so yeah he's at
like an IDF s like the worst kind
of the worst kind of Israeli supporter
there is nah bro I don't like Jeremy
either dude I heard Assan told me he's
going on Pierce Morgan I think he's
going on
tonight right and can't wait for that
and you should clarify cuz you said no
leftovers and I think everybody panicked
oh no it's not we canel the show H
is out of town twitchcon it's twitchcon
that this was something we knew was
happening beforehand yeah yeah this say
I didn't know that people would I didn't
even think about it like that oops
leftovers is not cancelled you
[Music]
guys I think we need leftovers more now
than ever in
fact you know what I mean
that being said I do look forward to
seeing him on Piers Morgan I wonder I
told H I was like he's going to try to
hose you that's like his thing I I think
he hates Hassan Hassan's been covered in
the media it's been covered by Ben
Shapiro he's the the America deserve 911
guy I think Piers is going to try to
hose
him we'll see I mean
that's undoubtedly why else would he be
invited he told him he's coming on to
Prov what they told him was that he's
coming on to provide
commentary so the former Israeli Prime
Minister is going on the show to talk
about it and then he's coming in
afterwards to provide commentary that's
what they told
him who Omar or with om I think yeah
yeah wow which is kind of crazy that is
very crazy which is cool for him I just
I think and he knows it I was like be
careful bro that guy's that guy is not
your friend just so you know
he knows that he does yeah yeah he's
well aware but hopefully he just
you
know uh and he probably will hand
himself really well what cam I used to
work at I I used to work with somebody
that was his producer at CNN uh and she
described him as a pig so behind the
scenes about right yeah
shocking a nightmare AB how's your cat
did you rescue it uh
Hamas killed the C oh my God
no are you sure it wasn't the IDF it was
the IDF I don't even joke dude they
missile striked the tree yeah I'm
allg and you know by the way the Israeli
media they're so untrustworthy that like
again I totally understand you
guys not wanting to not willing to
believe what they're saying I don't I
don't believe what they're saying either
I'm I'm taking it from other sources
well that's it we'll see we let's Let
Let It shake out whether you agree or
disagree let's just wait
okay unless you want Lebanon unless you
want Hezbollah to enter the
war which is objectively bad I
think for
everybody thank
you
everybody I got a challenge for love go
ahead every day I take these super green
Foods what is mix you mix it in a glass
of water that's and it's your vegetable
for this that's what I that's the
I've been trying to hit you want to hit
this hold do you have a empty Taco Bell
cup we can make you feel at home yeah
you do all right cool oh wait did I
forget my drink yo where's my Mountain
Dew zero at you guys I see it on the
table I uh I got the Pepsi Zero which I
had never tried before it was pretty
good it was gone I think I think I
probably prefer Coke Zero but it it was
it was an impressive zero sugar soda
yeah it's good oh thank you dude I got
to tell you guys sun kissed
zero Sun kiss zero Sun kiss is so no
zero I said this two weeks AG sod it's
insane wait was Zach did you did
you pitch this yeah I'm pretty sure we
we talked about this yeah I remember I
heard somebody recommend it so that's
why it was in my brain it's next level
bro right it it doesn't taste like Diet
right it I don't believe it it's crazy
yeah I find I'm I'm regular soda is too
much like nowadays me too I mean it's
crazy to drink that much sugar to the
Dome yeah uh I really have to pee so uh
I'm going to have Olivia take over the
switching so um nightm Good
Luck you guys are going to enjoy a weird
version of the show for a
minute you're not you're not there
you're not there I can't sleep it's a
nightmare a nightmare nightmare night
Nightmare
Night loves that he try to really enjoy
this song
I think we're I think we might be
helping his career out it's pretty good
in my opinion check this
out oh man is it sweet
cam yeah he's probably not I'm going to
try it right now I
don't love has got the uh green smoothie
paste drink he's tasting
it it doesn't look good does it taste
like gamer sub
hell though bro tastes like straight
dirt in a cup that's
Earth dude you're tasting in the earth
see this is what I feel like people
drink this they say it's good hell
no bro I don't think people think it
that tastes good bro no maybe just do it
I don't like it I'm not going to would
you try it I did I took like a sip and
I'm not going to continue doing it a
it's worth a shot you'll get there
you'll get there cam do you do you think
that tastes good or do you just drink it
cuz it's health no I drink it for
the nutrients yeah yeah there you go so
I don't have to eat veggies every day
put that in like a pizza for me or
something hide it now I can eat it all
right we tried thank you guys thank you
your dream of drinking vegetable powder
has ended yeah it ended it wasn't good
shame
yeah all right we actually have a lot of
other fun stuff to talk about so cut
that out of the way um let's
see this is a problem
[Music]
link of Rett and Link was on hoe
Mandel's
podcast and hoe who is one of my best
and closest
friends in this
world ow I would take a bullet for him
I'm pretty
sure listen to what he said to
link and I and Trigger warning this is
offense
for almost two years and I'm tell I
could say without a doubt the best hair
we've had I'm a big judge of hair oh
well Jack Jackie didn't I mean she
didn't take that bait no I think so I'm
thinking back to all the guests we've
had look this you want you want to
really consider
this see she
knows now granted link does have
incredible hair I mean his hair is
beautiful yeah it is beautiful
but I think it rides up his forehead
more than mine for sure absolutely it's
receded a bit right yes yeah he's
beautiful but it is it's gorgeous mhm
but it's receded a little bit Howie but
if you want to talk about like beautiful
hair he has beautiful hair you know what
I mean and it's not bad for a guy his
age like what is he 45 or
something he
is they're old unlik I'll tell you
something we've been doing this podcast
for almost 2 years and I'm
tell yeah he's 45 oh wow dude they look
amazing don't they holy
those guys are like super
humans you know he dyes his hair gray
those uh yeah what yeah it's not
naturally gray what links
[Music]
yeah he he I think he says that he is
his hair is graying slowly and that his
racing it but he's always dyed those two
front things I pretty sure that's pretty
wild
yeah
wow okay it's fashion yep I think it
looks good so yeah this is a problem
obviously how's going to have to reckon
with this there's going to be there's
going to be a lot of uh chatter there's
going to be lots of lots of
problems also going moving over to Emily
Baker friend of the show
um she made a really honest
mistake which I want
to uh just correct for her make sure
that she was speaking clearly here she
is
oops Ethan Klein and Harvey I'm sorry
Harvey Weinstein no Ryan Kavanaugh when
we saw that beef going back and forth
and Ryan Kavanaugh was like but you're
honor they did all of this and Ethan
Klein's like didn't tell them to do that
they were pissed off and a pissed off
audience can do quite a
lot but Ethan kleene
never disclosed Kavanaugh's information
never and by the way quite the contrary
I told everyone leave an honest good
hearted beautiful
review that's that's right by way I
heard the trailers like offline like
that you cannot post stuff there right
now really hases anyone have does anyone
on TR yeah I heard it's like totally
dysfunctional that's hilarious not let
me see not surprising though I mean I'm
surprised it's been funded this long
holy this is their homepage it's
empty look you made it to the end that's
sad this is their homepage you made it
to the end I just got here I guess they
mean the end of trailler yeah they must
dude triller's done scroll down
a little bit there's no scrolling down
that's so funny that's supposed to be at
the bottom of the scroll but it's just
on the front page now this is their
whole front page holy that's it
dude I love it so I don't I
don't even know why he's oh you see Mor
yeah how do I go down I can't I just
swipe down I'm seeing more uh trills as
they called you're seeing lots of trills
let me let me open are you on the phone
app no I'm on my computer I'm not logged
in either I'm going to do
Incognito it's the same thing dude I got
the same thing but then I like clicked
EXP we live and then I went back and
it's there so let me try triller TV
whatever the that is check back
soon oh here we go here we okay all
right so it's just dysfunctional you
said it flipped back and forth yeah it
was flipped and when you're not there
not there I mean here's a here's a post
with on the main page this is the second
featured
Trill it's a random couple's wedding
photography and it has 3,000 likes
is it ad it's an ad is it not I don't
see it disclosed that it's an ad huh I
don't think it's hash wedding
photography hash Fort Lauderdale wedding
photography very specific okay well tny
fet trouers in Fort Lauderdale Tri
County
Area who happen to be getting married
soon this is their second featured video
yeah yeah shout out youa pass it along
um so yeah triller's doing really good
you guys we're all we're all rooting for
them we're all rooting
from yeah hang in there Cav
Cav any day now it's going to take
off he's so funny sorry he's so funny
he's trying to say in the defamation
case oh now you made it to the end now
I'm at end he's starting to say in the
defamation case that triller has
failed and that he has been removed from
the board because of what I've been
saying about him angry and what's funny
about
that I and I don't want to put words in
his mouth that's I think alleged when I
say no I I mean that's pretty much what
they're saying that's what the
defamation damages are but what's funny
also is that in the lawsuit he's going
through right now with his like ex and
his kids he also said and that
trial that it was because of what she
said that he was losing business oh so
which one is it Cav
Cav it could be both everybody but him
yeah everybody it's everyone it's
everybody else's fault not me certainly
not my
fault yeah he's a good one by the way if
you guys want to learn more go to Google
or whatever search uh search engine that
you prefer type Ryan Kavanaugh spell his
name out Ryan
Kavanaugh uh let's take a look Wikipedia
is number one of course obviously two
number two is does Ryan kavan look like
rvy Weinstein uh click that fantastic
spend some time here look around
familiarize yourself it is a public
service obviously they do look alike and
certainly Ryan would not be want to be
mistaken for being Harvey Weinstein
which is why we've dedicated this
website to there many many differences
so go ahead take a look you know scroll
around
and oh oh I look like an
anime yo I got to say that's wow that
gray job he does that's expensive hair
care that's like real yeah he's
like in the salon with the bul the bulb
over his head and the plastic it's
beautiful it's gorgeous it is gorgeous
it's worth it going to be me soon dude I
I'm discovering more and more gray hairs
yeah he pays for it Zach you get it for
free what's the problem it's scaring me
dude how old are you uh just turned
26 I'm fine they just come in slowly I
think gray hair looks cool
yeah yeah I don't think it's a big
deal what is this saier this is on the
trailer website they have a bunch of
different Raffles you can this is on the
website yeah you can donate to a bunch
of these and you can win win the troller
wait no no no that's not oh they could
be guests what is this five lucky
winners and their guests get to attend
the triller compound for a day of summer
fun triller
compound valid this you get to come to
this house for a day cool and listen to
music what wait it was posted to yeah
and you'll be um
with the company of creators you know
and love yeah right that's sounds
great dude I guarantee all your favorite
creators on triller like the Fort
Lauderdale wedding
service God I would lose it yeah
Fort Lauderdale uh photography service
will be there so that's pretty big so
romantic there's a carpenter in Fort
Lauderdale who's contending he's big
there on
thriller so very exciting times for Ryan
and obviously I'm rooting for
him that's about it so shout out to
Emily
Baker um this I saw made me really
angry and I think that it's going to
piss you guys off especially you Dan is
really mean I'm so angry I'm so
angry especially me
yeah these pranksters are
what what is wrong with them man
it's like every generation there's a
whole
new I think YouTube needs to ban pranks
I think we just got to call it ban
pranks pranksters pranks it's a banable
offense watch this and tell me you
disagree vegan yeah would you like to
try our um vegan chicken may I may I see
it first yeah yeah why are you eating it
like that because I don't I don't trust
I don't trust me no damn I don't eat
animal you're vegan yes so you can eat
chicken no is this chicken
[Music]
yeah yeah I don't work for a restaurant
I'm just feeding vegetarian people with
chicken tast is good though no can we
get an
opinion
waa I'm trying to convert vegans I got
this some Popeyes I just trying to I'm
just trying to get people to eat more
meat why did you did that I told because
I don't like vegans I don't like vegans
I'm I have beef with you guys which is
kind of ironic I'm going to call the
police wait hold on hold on call the
police look now it's Fair what a
okay yeah but we got a ban all pranks
you're right you were on to something
this is the
worst what the
like what a dick I don't like
vegans I don't like I don't like
that you don't eat something bothers me
the top common is never trust that
haircut are you vegan that's you
like to that's like the aimc broom cut
almost h no he's got to shave a lot more
off a prick that is a prankster haircut
though if I've ever seen
one um yeah I was kind of just shocked
that is
insane what can you say about that dude
if someone stealth me with pork right
it's going down like yeah there's a lot
of stuff that I would just walk away
from that is one thing where it's like
that is so foul to intentionally be like
here try this it's chicken and be like
psych it's pork got
you that guy would have been fully in
his right to de count
man so there you go you agree we're
Banning
pranks yeah at first I you know not for
Collective punishment as we've discussed
in the last week but in this
case is it Collective punishment if
they're all probably pretty dumb and
stupid and annoying I mean it might be
but in this case we'll sanction it it's
like The Minority Report we know they're
going to do something dumb it just
hasn't happened yet
right which is why I'm suggesting all
pranksters need to get on a
train wonder how well that movie holds
up I remember really liking it did you
see the Remake wait there's a remake
right with Tom Cruz that's the one oh I
thought the only one that was good that
was Ste I'm talking about the Tom Cruz
one yeah that was a good
movie yeah it's good feel like it never
gets talked about I think it you're
right it doesn't get talked about it was
really good though Spielberg too right
spiel movie you guys I don't know if
some of y'all have seen it it was a big
movie when it came out but we're Old Dan
yeah this came out in 2002 man wow
what that's
crazy yeah watch it check it out it's
really
good good sci-fi flick uh did I mention
I donated 65,000 to you did just making
sure it was just mention again if you
want no I I didn't mean to mention it
again I just I was in the order of the
document and I got
confused oh I suppose I can take this uh
photo of you with this hair
off um let's see here Goofs and gffs you
guys you guys want to talk about quaries
y'all want to do
Jade always I've got a good Jade thing
for you guys we were talking Jade a
little bit oh you may have missed it so
there's a fan who left a Super Chat uh
saying
that they have a ton of Jade and that
they're like a geologist and they have a
rock cutter and they'd be willing to
help us come cut it and then we looked
into them and they they're like they're
big on Mineral talk they had 1.5 million
followers really yes they seem to be and
they're in
California do you think they'll come to
unun with me to yunan so here's here's
what when you were in the bathroom they
they sent a super chat but they also
messaged me on
Cameo um and they have a rock cutter uh
and they their Channel's mess you on
Cameo yeah they I there was some issue
with uh putting the message in the do
they have to pay to message you uh yes
how much did they pay uh
$6 that's great if you have any
inquiries to the show just message okay
so so it was a weird sequence of events
Ethan the way they became aware of this
is they left a $100 Super Chat and it
was it was kind of like a broken
sentence that didn't really make any
sense but it said one of the things that
it said was Zach Cameo and that caused
him to go look at his Cameo and sure
enough sent a message there uh so I'm
not sure how that all happened but the
message was received and um I guess
email me if you're if you are emerald
listen if we could get some live
Jade cutting going on up in this podcast
that' be wicked cool man I am deep deep
deep into Jade talk right now I'm
telling you guys but here is a new one
on the stone cutting craze that's taking
over this woman I can't even say that
it's part of the craze she's clearly
been doing this for a long time um she's
digging a quarry under her
house that's right she's
digging a
quarry yeah you sent this the other
night and I was I don't think I taking
back I've been following her for a long
long time so let's see what she's doing
here I have a lot of concerns about this
but let just watch this one got a new
challenge recently I've been exploiting
a single layer of hardened Sandstone it
is wonderful as the rock breaks easily
into blocks feel like I'm playing
Minecraft they will be easy to utilize
in my plans of constructing a tower off
the side of my house and eventually a
castle unfortunately the vein is getting
exhausted and thinner The Rock above and
below is too fragile to use for building
[Music]
it's now a couple days later and I have
some better
News 2 ft down from the exhausted layer
there appears to be more hard rock it
will take me a while to determine the
depth but the top part is very promising
to give a bit more context this is the
old layer and all the way down here at
25 ft is the new
one so far the rock that I've been
mining in this new layer is a bit more
fractured and smaller than the other one
but I can still use
it okay do we know this is really under
her house it I've been watching this for
a year at least it's her name is kala
and yeah she's just building a massive
cave under her house and it's super
fascinating where that can't be legal
that was kind of dig into the Earth yeah
I mean even if it's not illegal just uh
dangerous right what like caveen or
something no she's she she like steadies
it up and everything she puts uh metal
rods and then put C on the roof she does
it like according to listen I'm pretty
I'm pretty sure you need a permit for
that yeah I'm not I'm not denying that
hell but it's awesome she made this ma
like she's really smart she made this
massive like elevator that lifts up a
bunch of rocks and dumps it out it's so
sick cool do we know where she lives or
I've been trying to figure it out she
has I don't kala I don't know what that
she sounds American sounds American yeah
and so the question I guess is where in
the country is there's this type of
Bedrock under
homes here let's watch I mean if you go
down deep enough probably anywhere right
U I don't know actually I have no idea h
no clue I've developed a nice automated
process for removing Rock from my tunnel
system using this landworks mine cart I
am able to dump material directly into
no longer playing pretend this is for
real I can only run a dumpster for 2
weeks before acing a daily search charge
I cannot mind that test it is laborious
is she doing this all herself yeah
yeah I can't imagine she has many any
friends and I don't say that mean wait
but who just make an assumption who
needs friends when you're building a
mind under your house who better share
the mind my friends now maybe the Mind's
to get away maybe yo wait a
minute think she find any Jade down
there she could collab make a friend
Emerald I already have good ideas if we
can reach out to her maybe I can get
down there and help her dig oh yeah I
would love to guys could start a I think
we should let's let's try and make
contact we can bring the geologist with
and he can tell her why this is such a
bad idea yeah this is just this is a
geology podcast from now on yeah it's
awesome we're into Jade we're into
quaring we're Stone folk Stone crafting
Stone
folk I'm going to join I'm going to join
the Freemason three weeks or more to
exct different I'm in different thing no
they're all about Stones
yeah they're all about okay dope let's
do that a full 10 cubic
yards so I end up staging The Rock in my
basement this pile is 6 ft tall and
contains 8 cubic yards I am not
complaining because there is nothing
more rewarding than transferring Rock
from the P to the it feels like working
in an old assembly line but this is an
extra step which decreases
automation when designing a process
throughput is constrained by bottlenecks
it doesn't matter how much automation is
introduced if the bottleneck is not
address this girl has a lot of re
money that's why I'm thinking she's not
from America and maybe like
a yeah where it's cheaper to get things
whatever this looks expensive I don't
care where you are yeah you know she has
like a complicated pulley electronic
pulley system
yeah her the name of her channel is
engineer everything so maybe she's got a
really good
job just maybe she's entreprene
hobby she's what an entrepreneur like
Gary ve oh she's looking for different
perspectives from down below that's why
she's getting down so
[Laughter]
low there's New Perspectives down there
dude send Gary ve to
Gaza he would settle this wait that's
why you're saying that right okay got it
listen here's the thing what's bet the
only thing better than being born rich
is being born in Gaza true there's
nothing more motivating that gets me
hungrier than being bomb than being born
in a war torn bombed out hell hole
that's how you yeah now put that phone
down
through hardship he he will rise
above wait there was a Gary ve thing
that I sent you guys that there was
where was do we have that of him you're
talking about the the beer
one yes yeah do we have that I don't
believe so let me look at the chat I
know the exact here I'm just going to go
to his Instagram instag
post I think he's I think he's lost the
plot I think he's fallen
off uh is his engagement down
yes here here it is
uh talking about different perspectives
here I'll send
it
uh it has 800,000 almost 900,000 views
so 26,000 likes though yeah the likes
aren't great the views on Instagram are
generally pretty high yeah I suppose
that's true so check this one was a hit
for him though like this is more than
all the rest of his but that's what
I'm saying dude he has fallen off if his
good post are doing
26,000 um oh this one has that's a
sticky that's why this one has 14,000
he's quoting himself he's doing Tai
Lopez you guys the number one
reason that people struggle with time
management is because they beat
themselves up for not having shut up
knowledge what is it that's way too much
text for like a weak like you need to
make that snappier that's a whole
paragraph absolutely but this guy
already got the bag scamming people
scamming knowledge selling people vend
yeah definitely want me to take their
money soon has 2,000
likes uh it says the person who sent you
this wants to grab a coffee with you and
Gary thought Gary was like I'm gonna
post this bomb
content I'm going to make a video that's
going to get so much engagement they're
going to send it to all their Pals
that's right check the Eng are the
craziest videos what cam uh check the
engagement on the link I just sent okay
his finest Hour okay let's see here when
he's Shrek posting Shrek posting yeah he
did what now when I hear 22-year-olds
say they haven't made it yet you know
who liked this post who Sebastian Mark
Zuckerberg sh
what that's sh Co is he saying is
he saying that's embarrassing yeah I
don't know yeah yeah yeah oh maybe here
will it
will saying got five more Liv okay okay
yeah kind
of that's one of
his really I mean it probably with
modern medicine four to five more lives
more lives so imagine why I get so upset
when you're stressed that you haven't
done it yet I get the feeling this guy
never listens to anyone ever he's just
always talking at people
always he's I don't hate what he's
saying here though well yeah I mean he
just stop talks all damn day yeah but
like like that's the thing like compared
to let's just say all of the uh Alpha
influencers out there at least his
message is not as tox it's toxic I don't
think his message is as toxic as Alpha
guys but telling somebody that they
shouldn't feel bad for not being
successful at 22 okay first of all that
is conventional knowledge okay I
don't not in his world though that's the
thing not in his world you're a
loser if you haven't made it dude what
you haven't started businesses what 22y
old in today's society that is totally
stacked against you in every single
imaginable way is doing anything with
their life like
genuinely um and I love you guys uh I'm
I'm with you my spirit is with you but
the reason I guess Gary ve is funnier is
because how how serious people take them
I think that's the part that tickles me
he a little bit more uh mainstream
anyway here's the video that pissed me
off person who sent you this wants you
to
know he put the coffee in you guys it
says be I think one time my mom sent me
one of these I was like the person who
sent you this wants you to know and then
it said like you're a wonderful daughter
or something very cute and sappy what is
this Gary are you like a 16-year-old
what girly things are what the is
this be also what if you
what if you're a serial killer be you
yeah some people should not less like
you and more like me some of yall really
need to yeah Gary you should be more
like me yeah it it's not a universal
advice sometimes being you is just the
wrong damn thing to do yeah you want to
be you know run away from that not
everybody most of people that's good
advice but I would you see this is why
I'm this is why I would be a great
motivational speaker
also isn't that message weird for him
because he like always challenging
people to get outside their comfort zone
and stuff which goes against message
interesting it's kind of contradictory
which is almost like be is like you know
different perspectives whatever comes
naturally to you
right don't listen to me just be do
yourself yeah anyway I thought it was so
corny like bro you posted this I like
that it pissed you off so bad it's so so
stupid it's very stupid this is the but
I like I didn't get mad I just kind of
laughed I just like what is wrong with
this guy that he thought to post this
you're so bothered it's just
absurd absurd wait usb2 2002 is asking
no one really asked but how are you bro
you the person reading this oh wait
they're really trying to break through
I'm just looking at this comment the top
comment on the they're talking to me
video to you oh that was the on the
video video how are you doing out there
everybody listening how are you guys
doing how are you I hope you're all
being you today a nightmare a
nightmare um God I could watch Gary ve
videos all day man let's do it should we
well let's look into more engineering
forever or
everything let's see let's just look at
one of her new ones like what's she up
to in the garden veg Garden oh that's
like that looks like a normal ass
neighborhood
look at
that this is my vegetable garden it's
been a bountiful year not for vegetables
but for weeds I have a small of
strawberry bright she would be an
interesting trumpet vine but I'm
thinking it might be something else
she's definitely being CL be you and a
little bit of ragweed I love the smell
of rwhat most importantly is this
English ivy she's got Style
he does posting up in the bushes I don't
I didn't this one wasn't checked so I
don't know if the audio
is careful careful now yeah she would be
that would be a really interesting guess
I I have something important to ask
though go ahead I'm hearing a lot of
talk about this Pit and the Rocks
collecting the rocks and how it's all
going towards this goal building a
castle I don't understand the castle
part it an admirable goal someone who
also wishes to have a castle total
respect you're still bro Are you
seriously going to call yourself a
socialist huh you want a castle you
think I want Ethan I want everyone to
have a castle okay if you understand
fair enough fair enough don't you need
peasants and at your Castle huh you
need peasants at your Castle there's a
lot of you're thinking more you're
thinking more of like a Manor I don't
want a manner I want cast you need
servants at the
castle you count I don't need servants I
don't need servants I'm just I'm
interested in the in the real estate you
just want space
anding and I want to be able to dress up
like a knight and pretend like I'm
battling monsters is that so much to ask
anyways my point is I respect the
goal where is the progress on the castle
I was scrolling through all right I see
a lot of digging see a lot of talk about
castle I feel like you have enough at
this point to at least get started yeah
let let's make the mope do you play
fortnite dude you got to get the
material before he build knows what
she's doing yeah but she does she knows
what she's doing D she actually even
tried a cement pouring around her house
so she's working up uh fine tuning her
like strategies and stuff like that and
then she's going to build a castle the
castle is the castle is a new addition
to the lore to the to the recent
development yeah it's like a couple
weeks ago underground Castle okay no
it's going to be on top yeah well she
just building a foundation like a
parking garage is she building the
dungeon right now she's building a
dungeon yeah she's building a dungeon oh
interesting I guess you would need to
start with that wouldn't you yeah okay
here is an interesting comment someone
said what do you do for work she said
computer engineer that pce well you go
yeah I mean some some jobs pay crazy
good if you're depends who you work for
how much experience but I've heard of
computer Engineers making almost a
million dollars yeah damn if you're like
senior and work for the big companies
it's crazy stem we love it what women
and stem we love it we love women in
stem oh we love stem women we're
standing so hard right now mhm it makes
sense too cuz she does like really
advanced math just yeah she's all the
time clearly
insanely like this smart yeah I'm going
to say this is
probably somewhere in the
South looks like maybe New England eh
different heights to get them but I
could be wrong she's doing PSI
measurements here guys wow we are
measuring she wants to measure we
charting how far down her mind goes but
obviously it's vertical and down and up
and down and up so she uses pressure
meure mental man yeah wow so she Cates
the how much pressure is equals to feet
it's very cool oh wow yeah wow so there
it is her name is a engineer everything
Tik Tok Kyla oh she has a YouTube
channel oh she has an Amazon wish list
let's see what she's
got we can buy her she wants uh this
appears to be stuff to to help make the
castle which uh which is Noble goal yeah
we need a c dude she's so who the
else I need a cement mixer I need a land
work utility service wheelar why is that
cart so expensive oh is it like powered
that it does it have a LIF that heav
yeah she lifts uh that's how she gets
rid of her rocks yeah oh I hope she
Updates this cuz she already has one of
those maybe it's breaking she needs more
yeah maybe it's breaking she wants a
power
drill
Jackhammer this is some crazy ass
battery that cost
$2,000 so well done
oh is it yeah mhm also you can buy her
pillows I don't think that's what that
is you can buy her some crown molding
apparently she's asking for crown
molding oh
that's that's just for the house I guess
that's just for her enjoyment that's not
for the castle and she wants a book here
you can buy yourself a book girl the
storm of
K in a book first account of World War I
trench combat oh trenches has to do with
digging she's got passions there you go
she's consistent she wants this shirt
apparently she
wants suggestion she wants this
Tillman flame retardant okay M I
got that for you she wants a flame
retardant shirt girl you need to be
careful it's probably to uh to Welden
right yeah for sure she wants this gold
pendant that's can we buy that
for her oh that's a beautiful pendant
it's called romantic jewelry Christmas
present for
wife okay
interesting my on another page she wants
zero proof rum awesome zero alcohol free
rum yeah interesting feel like I'm
learning so much about her huh well
there it is so much to see so much to
learn this such an interesting thing
that people do with the uh mhm the
public like hey can someone buy me this
book yeah I want to do that I'm just
going to make a public wish I bet people
they'll hook you up Dan I'm we
should all do I'll promote your Dan
Dan make your Amazon I don't know I
don't have anything that I want that's
the problem oh I'm sure you could think
of many things there's a lot of good
books out there yeah maybe some books
vegetables vegetable books bu me veget
vegetable books all right let's see
we're rounding out here uh it's been
what how long's it been uh 3 hours 23
minutes and 7 Seconds
oh and how many how long now uh we're up
to 11 12 13 14 would you like me to keep
you updated I'm good
16 coming up on 20 right now do we have
something on Friday or is it a
normal cuz there's a lot of here I
want to uh not this
Friday the next one oh I saw people um
and may we should just address uh cuz we
had mentioned that Curtis Connor was
coming on soon on the show and I saw a
lot comments asking what happened he was
supposed to come last Friday which was
the episode we ended up canceling to
take a personal day so unfortunately it
just didn't happen but we'll get him
back on in the uh near future well Al
also was like bro you don't want to you
don't want to be in close yeah it was in
the midst of all of this war talk and
it's not a good time for you for anyone
want drag him into
that uh also this up and coming Friday I
will not be here Zachy
Miss come
on yay the snooze conventions in town so
you know I got to Zach give us a smile
brighten up our
day not that not that smile maybe just
smile enough just the smile
please oh
yeah um okay good because there's a lot
of stuff here I want to talk about still
like
um this new Alpha Male that says I just
talk about
cats and then there's the SC this guy
who harasses Scientologist which is the
cap video that's right we were supposed
to talk about that on Monday we didn't
get to it and then there's another thing
I really want to talk about that oh yeah
my new Cairo champ the Vampire
Hunter sick so I can I can say here let
me just pull yeah we got
a we got to uh how do you say uh fill
time on Friday so
uh why do you say
that if we if we don't do it today then
we get a head start on Friday yeah yeah
for sure that
uh this
is no this isn't the one I want I want
to watch the the cat guy hold
on this
is get a load of this kid man what is
everybody saying eel pit I'm seeing a
lot of eel there Tik Tok thing yeah
there's another person on Tik Tok who
similarly has Doug right and eel pit
what we should do we should do a deep
dive on Friday of that really Rabbit
Hole I love the e pit so I know
everything about the eel really why you
holding out on me I've never heard of
this okay so Friday we'll do a eel pit
report de also something really fun
that's gonna happen on Friday is um so
Tom Ward everyone's favorite is calling
in on Friday to share his
expertise and appliances specifically
dishwashers to endle end the
lifelong debate
that says you do not need to pre-rinse
dishes before they go in the washing
machine this is a raging debate that's
been happening
worldwide uh we're going to be doing
some experiments Dan already has strong
opinions which I'll ask you to hold hold
them just know that I've learned a lot
in the last 24 hours I've learned a lot
yeah no that's true he's washer woke
bro and he's turned me he's turned me
are you washed or are you dirty bro yeah
I've already converted Zach he's been
evangelizing the whole office I can't
shut up about it I don't even have a
washing machine all right let me watch
this dude and then we can leave all
right all
right oh yeah well I'll also be debating
uh the Israel and Gaza conflict with Tom
right uh so stay tuned um thoughts on a
one State versus a two- state that
that's my new favorite question for
anyone oh here you heard of
him oh started over yeah yeah yeah here
I just turned it
up all right Jacob lay it on me bro H3
H3 you've heard of him yeah of course
dude he's so demented in his
brain they talk about the most like
farted he talks about like cats bro
and all this dumb yeah I'm like bro
people who watch that I literally look
at it as like you're microwaving your
body you're microwaving your brain your
thought
process is that phenomenal or what that
sounds like somebody who's watched a lot
of H3 podcasts for sure just that's the
thing that you drew on that I talk about
cats I mean there's so many things I do
talk about that are off color cats is
one I can't say that I've talked a lot
about not a frequent topic of
conversation on this show what did he
even see I can't even I can't even think
of a clip where I'm talking about cats
ever Myan cat his defense I brought up a
cat today but that was the first time I
recall true I guess you're right we
talked yeah I can't stop talking about
cats you gave an apology to cats like
one year ago that was like you did
because you talk that's the that's
why this really doesn't have a lot of
credibility because anybody that knows
you knows that one of your biggest
flaws is
your hatred I'm openminded I'm
open-minded that being said I'm
definitely a dog person let's put it
that way it's fine to prefer dogs but
what is not fine I just I don't have
good experience I'm a I'm a I'm a cat
ctist you just need some EXP exposure
man you guys just got to adopt just
adopt a little kitten dude you
know I'm doing a little bit of a
deep di of when we talked about cats a
lot and we did talk about the cat movie
quite a bit or the cat like live action
thing okay that was Cat movie was so so
insane talk about that a considerable
amount was that what you Me Maybe he
talking about Cats the musical let's
watch it again Andrew lightwe I need to
watch this nice one absolutely it he
starts by showing this photo Dam mind
all right you've heard of him yeah of
course dude he's so demented in
his brain they talk about the most like
farted he talks about like also
like what did you use this clip of me
dancing and having fun and just you know
like a the whole cuz you look like a
fool I guess you look like C bro and all
this dumb yeah like bro people who
watch that what the
it's just the weirdest um CR
criticism maybe ever I got to say
through the years there's been some wild
people say about you this so
off but this is definitely the
most like what the is talking about
just bizarre he fell off he talks about
cats now talk about cats and
awesome who can listen to that I mean he
can say what we talk about toilets too
much F oh my God there's so many
things you can say we talk about too
much that's legit Harvey wein I'm always
getting banned I'm a hater I'm I just
spread negativity whatever like these
all Annoying ignorant stupid
dumb ass yeah all that stuff
work the
cats I literally look at it as like
you're microwaving your body you're
microwaving your brain your thought
microwaving your body cool sounds Co
even mean yeah
man I don't know man but I feel like my
body
microwave body bro so should I try to
reach out to have this guy call we had
that other guy but he he missed the
moment he missed the moment he tried
like a week later
he was like hey can we do this but
um destiny came knocking and he he
turned off the lights and hid behind the
couch pretending nobody was home so this
kid is selling a program how to make
$10,000 a month oh man that's crazy by
the way the one about me of course gets
more views than his average not a lot I
mean look at this this guy doesn't even
get although this yo this one got
900,000 so let's oh wow in 2012 I bought
200 iPhone cases I went to a swap meet
it's like a market and you could bring
stuff this is a fake podcast this is a
fake story so M's not even plugged in
it's called Jak oh really his mic is it
plugged in his audio his audio is pretty
good mistake I've had in life so far I
can see the cable hanging down but
what's this fake podcast Trend that you
see in the alpha world in 2012 just make
a real podcast you've gone through all
the work yeah they don't have that much
to say dud we should make first segment
we should make like five Tik Tok
accounts of five different
[Music]
podcast
anyway I went to a swap meet Market
bring
some here is a here's this one has
900,000 views let's see let's listen oh
I'm buttoned cuz I made a joke that
wasn't funny not offensive yeah for sure
not offensive at all yeah it wasn't that
it was offensive it was just it landed
really flat nobody laughed yeah it
wasn't good I buttoned I panicked is
this the longest we've gone without
hitting the button oh right I should
write that down I think there's been
episodes where we didn't hit it really
oh I think so all right here in
2012 I bought 200 iPhone cases I went to
a swap meet it's like a market and you
could bring stuff this man is talking to
people that doesn't know what a swap
meate is he says I went to the swap
meate it's like a
market I didn't need that and you could
bring stuff and you rent to swap me is
kind of like a weird term I don't know
what a swap me is doesn't everybody know
what a swap meat is does anybody here
not know what a swap meat is I don't
know other than love but but that's okay
cuz it's I think it's a cultural thing I
don't know Olivia I have no idea what
that is okay yeah are kind of old
school dude shiver me timbers me Tim
it's like what it was when I was a kid
my dad used to love this cuz he's a
cheapo it's a giant lot and
everybody just comes in and sets up
booths and sells all their junk yeah
it's crazy kind of like a uh impromptu
Mall almost but just like with
individual little like booze of people
selling I used to go to the Valley
Swap Meet every Saturday yeah I used to
go to that
one anyway okay I stand corrected Jacob
well done swap me it's like a market and
you could bring stuff and you rent a
spot the spot was 50 bucks I bought the
cases myself it was $10 for 10 cases on
Amazon so I bought 200 and this one dude
he went up to me the only guy I pretty
much bought from us and he came up to me
and he was like I I realized in
retrospect he was hitting on my mom he
gave me a $100 bill he's like
how much does this get me and I was like
10 and this guy's like I want
two and then leaving this place that's
the only ones I sold pretty much
everyone's broke as there it was a
terrible ideal customer was not there 12
years old so it was terrible
business plan in what was the point of
that video wow he's like I had this
brilliant idea when I was a kid it was
horrible it was dumb nobody nobody
bought anything just there was one mom
for money there was one weird dude who
was trying to my mom and he gave me
a 100 bucks he has for two mommies
instead of one yo dude that's the what
kind of Al this is the weirdest red
pill your brain's too microwave to
understand your your body's too
microwave body is nuked right now if we
put it in cat terms would you maybe
understand
that God that was the weirdest
Alpha video get through Ethan what I'm
seeing a lot of people say they know
swap meets as flea markets which same
thing
shout out to the uh the Florida swap
meat flea market and Broward anyone any
of our Florida viewers will know that
place is insane in insane that
place I've seen someone get stabbed
there okay that's fun yeah you never
know what you find at the Swap meate
might be a body good deals though good
great deals this one has 5 million views
you know what's even cooler than one of
these things having one downstairs and
the reason I say that is because you
probably think I'm like one of these
other guys in this half goes and ches to
sell you something I'm not here to sell
you guys anything what I will say is
that I who's buying from this
15-year-old I mean I don't know how old
he is but uh written he's in a high
building I think 21 okay I'm glad he's
not 15 actually that wouldn't be good
he's he's
21 absolutely which is the perfect age
to buy a course from somebody right I
have an application form below where I
will personally teach you and just show
you the ropes of what I've been able to
do to do well overall support myself in
life and if that's something you're
interested in you want to have a mentor
and someone to guide you you can apply
below and I'll send you a text if it
looks like a good fit do a quick intro
callit why does this have so many views
oh he must have run this as an ad has no
comments okay this is an ad dude
likelihood of you being successful at my
age is based on luck it's like this
guy's 21 the most likely is that he's
lucky not talented there's also a
willingness no he's really smart and
business savy it seems and he knows how
to make a really good podcast
I'm looking for a mentor that flea that
flea market story really you know
resonated with me yeah it felt very
powerful to me
um okay this is interesting okay okay I
see what's going on this has 3 million I
have an opportunity this also an ad
interesting of the reason I'm saying 5%
is because frankly I'd say 90 95% of
people watch this video aren't going to
do well oh yeah I was going to say I
think a lot of people Tak that but also
so it's a lot of how much of a giant
piece of are you willing to be cuz
there's a lot of things that a dude like
this I don't know him so I'm just making
an assumption but a lot of the dude like
this and all the like Wann to be
entrepreneurs like they have no scres
they will do the most shady to make
money and I feel like if you're willing
to just you know break the law to scam
people to be dishonest then you could
probably get rich pretty fairly easily
mhm
but you have to become py trust I mean
you see it at a small scale at
restaurants when there's like the the
weight staff that try to upsell everyone
I don't know if you guys know what I'm
talking about there's a type like the
dude who's like 40 still working there
no offense if that's one of you guys bu
uh and just like super aggressive not
giving a
there it
is he should just go sell he should go
drop you'd be way
richer go sell some fake Co masks
on a fake podcast really you your
current mindset you're perspective I'm
here to tell you a simple thing if you
want to work directly with me you want
me to Mentor you I'm here to do that you
can apply below you're so lame dude
we've seen this so many times yeah it's
the same old same old that's why I was
kind of like to the call idea look so
he's got all these videos and then all
of a sudden he's like oh I got to
get on this Ethan hate bad those videos
are popping off I think probably
ironically was that he probably doesn't
even know who you are clearly not all he
knows is that you talk about cats yeah
so the comments are Cheers my dude and
anyone else never heard of
h3h3 thanks bro now this person has you
can see why this one really connected
with his audience this is from two days
ago so cheers the cam grumpy cheers my
I'm going like that love you cheers cam
grumpy love you cheers cheers my dude
love you
love you no homo I'm right love you no
homo all right so that's it that's the
show
people so remember tomorrow there is no
leftovers and not because it's
cancelled but because it's VidCon yeah
twitchcon twitchcon yeah twitchcon and
Hanan I don't know if you guys know this
is a twitch a twitcher a twitch person
mhm good luck with all of that so good
you can't even make conspiracy theories
this was already planned and actually
moreover we should say that um maybe I
don't want to
say what just in case it doesn't work
out because it's not a th% confirmed but
we have big guest next Thursday oh it's
not 100% confirmed not it's let's say
it's 99% but we just we just did the
bait and switch with Curtis Connor so
I'm being a little cautious so yeah
hopefully it comes through cuz that
would be a real be a spicy episode I'm
going to have to do a lot of prep for
that one yeah but it'll be worth it
yep all right everybody well thanks for
playing he podcast here on this
beautiful Wednesday evening 5:00 p.m.
beautiful sunset outside go ahead look
out the window get some fresh air give
your kids a
kiss and
remember if you're feeling
down just
don't this is
yours Ethan Klein signing
[Music]
out